there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock you guys out there it's
episode 158 yeah this one's by popular
request some people on Tom Cheney movies
you know which is one of a month one of
my facebook groups actually is my only
Facebook um knew that this one was
common okay because they knew that I was
doing some research on bushido it was
[ __ ] martial art yeah how this all
started
something reminded me of it recently you
know access all bloodsport and [ __ ] and
how this all got started in my life is
uh when I was a kid and for about a year
at one for one year I'm because my
stepdad and everything me and my mom
moved to Michigan why we're in Michigan
I had a stepbrother there and he was
like a second degree Taekwondo black
belt [ __ ] was a badass he could
use all these weapons he's got all these
tournaments he'd do uh it was like
full-contact sparring but he had pads on
it was it's quite impressive well even
got even more impressed when he started
beating dudes asses at school I seen
beat like two or three dudes asses
simultaneously it was pretty impressive
but then like afterwards asking him
about it turns out he wasn't really used
in that Taekwondo he's only using the
punches and the kicks and he could kick
somebody in the face but he really
wasn't using all the the fancy stuff
that Taekwondo would do like these big
flying kicks you know you didn't use any
of those he just used the very basic
stuff and of course it he couldn't use
the weapons on people you know the
weapons were mostly just for show at
these tournaments so I was like a big
believer in martial arts as long as you
didn't
his martial arts what he was doing you
know and then on the other hand I got
this had this other friend named Mike
and he had a body who was from Woodhaven
when he went to another high school and
his name was Jim and he was going to one
of these dojos and run around like a
ninja we used to call him ninja Jim dude
had ninja yeah ninja Jim he'd stand
there like with his arms out like he was
at the ready position like he was in his
dojo all time where that [ __ ] gig you
know would go out you know he was a real
goofball yeah he believed in change [ __ ]
and I think never saw Jim fight he did a
lot of talk and never saw him fight that
always the way the Sun he bowed up on
him he put us out like he wasn't there
he tried vanish yeah so from an early
age I got had the idea that there were
martial arts that worked and then there
were other martial arts that didn't work
good call
Bushido [ __ ] oh yeah all right so
we're trying to straighten out some
[ __ ] oh here and some ninja stuff
and then you know I've been studying it
recently and some of it you some would I
go way back with some of this you know
it's gonna be a good show yeah this this
should actually be pretty fun because
some of the some of the peoples that are
that come up under like martial arts
frauds and stuff like that they're
hilarious one guy in particular and I'm
might like put some video of him just
yes I can't believe how [ __ ] funny it
is my friend ninja Jim was kind of like
a sheet of kin if anybody know
suggestion I'm talking about where he
will get into that leeway but my
step-brother Billy was he was like I
don't know he was like an early MMA guy
this is before UFC and MMA yeah you know
the whole idea of like full-contact
martial arts really was kind of like you
were you were treading the edge of like
something meaty criminal you know I mean
back yeah and everybody fought with
Tad's but turns out there were guys that
we're trying to do it bare knuckled
going all the way back to the 60s we're
gonna talk about this
and you know they were kind of the
pariahs of the martial arts scene and
you'll find out we're gonna tell the
whole story
yeah but definitely and like I said
we've he's got with me and like watching
all these videos about all these
different frauds and stuff like that
there's one guy who's that one guy's
channel we've been watching a lot of the
paint man he's got some good stuff
there's another guy I don't remember his
name but the pink man's my favorite one
he's the one that put point you the
right direction but yeah Bushido
this is this is somebody that like I
said I can't wait till he gets the part
about a cheetah camp because I what I
really want to show he sounds awesome
I really want to put some [ __ ] from his
little videos yeah and also from one of
his books Percy one in particular which
just really really I'm not gonna pay I'm
not gonna buy the [ __ ] and I can pay for
it but I read like some reviews of it
that had quotes from it and it sounds
yeah and I can explain a lot what's
going on with Bushido too as we go when
time comes maybe I'll talk about it
after we talk about the ninja yeah yeah
we wanted to do instead of all like
related but you know as soon as ninjitsu
as we're done talking with ninjutsu
remind me I will explain where bullshi
dough comes from okay there are real
martial arts and there's [ __ ] oh and
yeah one martial art as a whole we're
just [ __ ] on it's it's almost kind
of like and there's a little bit and
we'll probably talk about this a little
bit when you talk about like Frank Dux
and people like that there's a little
bit of like a stolen valor thing going
on to where it's like these guys you
know they claim they have all these
powers that they don't really have or
they claim that they have all this
fighting experience that they don't
really have yeah so it's kind of the
same thing as like people that say
they're naval and all that kind of [ __ ]
so that's what we're talking about there
are fake UFC fighters there are fake MMA
fighters but they just fake it in a
different way yeah talk about all that
yeah alright so first thing I want to do
just a couple of shoutouts first we have
a new patron this week on our patreon
page and her name is Virginia
so hello there and thank you very much
for your support
of the show thank you very much um also
as I said on the show before and I put
the commercial in the middle of this
episode and I put it in the middle of
last one - is that faceless villain
volume three which covers true crimes
unsolved murders from 1980 to 1999 is
out in print and ebook format now the
audiobook format should be out pretty
shortly because I applauded the files a
little more than a week ago and usually
it takes between 10 to 14 days like to
go through quality control and stuff
like that so it might be up by the time
this comes out but maybe not but it's
not gonna be very long like it'll
definitely be probably the same week
that this goes up like it'll be should
be up this week so I'll let everybody
know
on the page when that happens and I'll
put it on my blog and everything like
that as well so that's pretty much all
the shoutouts I think that we have so
let's get into talking about the ninja
yeah
now when you know let me back up real
quick okay when we were kids in our
generation growing up in the 1980s
alright we didn't have the Internet all
we had was damn movies and magazines
Magne there was like some Stone Age [ __ ]
and a lot of the movies ever that was
had it started to happen in the eighties
the young guys would watch for these
[ __ ] ninja movies yes a lot martial
arts movies there's always some kind of
ninja in it so you'd just by osmosis
you'd have some friends that we're doing
martial arts or you could go right down
to 7-eleven and look at a black belt
magazine and see nothing but mail-order
advertisements for ninja gear like a
ninja boots and ninja swords and just
all this martial arts stuff so if you
had guys you had friends who were
involved in you would hear all these
stories about ninja and you really
weren't sure what was true your your kid
you're not gonna go to the library and
if there's a library it's not gonna have
much
ninja okay yeah and there was no
internet to really verify these claims
oh you know [ __ ] like death touches
throwing stars
you know comma weapons which is like a
damn stick with a sigh on the end of it
you know
you just see these vicious looking
weapons and Dragons and derpy [ __ ] like
that and you're like yeah it might be
something to it
[ __ ] might be something so we didn't
know we're ninjas really came from we
just thought there was something that
maybe existed right now in Japan yeah
that you could go that you could move to
Japan and good and ninjas and become a
ninja and they don't teach you yes
really cool [ __ ] you weren't you quite
sure you put on your little black
pajamas you would like go through this
rigorous training routine yeah yeah
cause I might be involved sure yeah and
then you know then you would graduate
and they would give you your little box
throwing stars video games are a pure
video games called shinobi yeah bad
dudes the Street Fighter you know all
this was just like part of the the
Gestalt of the 80s there was god that
was [ __ ] everything with so many
[ __ ] engines ninjas they and
everything has gone OLED just had a
certain air of credibility yeah you know
when you're 16 17 yeah you don't know
different that might be a thing and
that's you know it's you know especially
like I said it's if you know it's a
country that's half with it's all the
way around the world right and you know
you don't know what they're up to over
there it's like they could have all that
[ __ ] we're gonna discuss kind of a his
historicity of ninja yeah and I'm gonna
tell you right now schooler alert the
ninjas that you see in the movies when
everybody if you say the word ninja when
everybody thinks that was the guy in the
black suit with just the eyes showing
yeah and swords of throwing stars or
whatever who's like super sneaky and
sometimes has magical powers like
depending on what the movie was or what
story is yeah um I hate to burst
anyone's bubble but still believe in
[ __ ] yeah but that's no that's that's
not how that worked
yes
this all started in the 1500s
during the Japanese warring States
period it was not a unified country I
don't even believe I believe they had
samurai but I don't think it was a real
rigid class system I think you can get a
job as one which basically meant like
professional soldier yeah the same way
you could become a knight if you had
enough money you could buy the armor and
you could go out and find a job yeah it
was kind of like that you know there was
no emperor it wasn't United and they
also just had soldiers guys with
matchlock rifles and you know they even
have explosives you know actually that
went on for a long time so that's when
it all started this warming States
period go ahead and tell him about it
Jim
yeah so originally really the word ninja
didn't even kind of come into play until
probably what the 17th 18th century yeah
after it had happen after this stuff had
already happened here now what we would
I you know it's like I hesitate to say
because you know the word ninja just
says it's it's basically a folkloric
yeah that word doesn't a figure that
word doesn't appear until around the
1800s yeah now the closest analogue and
you know where a lot of the historical
sources say that it comes from was
coming from what they would call a
shinobi there's this word shinobi yeah
there's some accounts of attacks on
castles the guy would write stuff like
yeah we got attacked it was a shinobi
action they burned down this house over
here and that one over there and the
leader of the the leader of the of the
guard said that they were that they were
from you know endo or some other little
town that was near them so it just said
it was a shinobi action yeah all right
there's a lot of stuff like this so you
had samurai
in the 1700s reading this thinking you
know well what's a shinobi there must be
some shinobi out there that do this yeah
because the samurai wouldn't do that
yeah wrong shinobi was more like a
mission
it meant like a covert mission or a
commando mission that's what it meant
yeah it started out more as like a
descriptor it wasn't talking about a
person necessarily it was talking about
a person you know doing these covert
actions like undercover charts like
sneaking around doing spy [ __ ] you know
what I mean
you are you know kind of going
undercover and like getting information
by like dressing as a farmer or
something like that but samurai the
1700s are reading to this account that
comes from the 1500s and they can't
imagine one of their own kind doing this
kind of mission because it's kind of
it's a sneak attack that's kind of
Dishonored yeah yeah so they think that
there's a special class of warrior
called a shinobi yeah that's what
they're thinking that does this kind of
does this kind of mission because they
sure as hell wouldn't do it but that's
where they're [ __ ] up back in the
1500s samurai and soldiers of all
description did that kind of stuff it's
just why wouldn't you it's a normal it's
a normal operation for for any kind of
army that you have to have Scouts you
have to have you know reconnaissance
Scouts spies which is like a scout
that's pretty much the same thing you
also need saboteurs and you need to get
not guys they can do raids nighttime
raids yeah burn up the enemy supplies in
other words you're kind of like cheating
yeah you're a sneak attack and burning
up their food to weaken them in the
coming days when the battle is gonna
happen there's yeah that kind of stuff
well the samurai didn't think that they
would do that but in the 1500s they did
they're talking about professional
soldiers under the command of some local
warlord this warlord trust them he's not
subbing subcontracting this work out to
just random ninja ninja dudes in black
suits you know that he doesn't know you
know it's his own men doing it yeah okay
so I'm reading this and I'm going
[ __ ] for those who don't know me you
know I was in I'm a recon soldier I was
with the first and three to seven recon
platoon you know
I'm a skel so really reading this I
found out that I was a ninja I'm a
[ __ ] that's what I did so I'm a ninja
[Laughter]
yeah that's exactly the thing it just
seems like it seems like and shinobi
like I said as a word is more like a
description of what of like an action
it's not like talking about the person
that kind of happened later on means
they're like a covert rage sneak attack
yeah it's um you know it means to hide
or to steal away or something like that
over it off so that's basically all it
was and then as the years went on and oh
you know what might be a good word
that's very close to it raid yeah we
were raided yeah Raiders hit us you know
we didn't that's what they're talking
it's kind of like that cuz a Raider has
to be covert right you know sneak attack
yeah so they're talking about I mean
there are you know records of this type
of raid or this type of attack going
back to like the 12th century you know
really the first mentions of like
shinobi attacks are from the 15th
century but as you said as the years
went on and people started people in
later centuries the 17th 18th century
started reading about these shinobi
attacks yeah and started to think that
this was a type of person or a type of
soldier yeah
and that they started to kind of like
put together a whole mythology so a
whole legend is a real thing yeah in the
same way as the Jedi never existed but
they exist now you can go to a
convention and see one yeah it's
lightsaber and everything it's kind of
happening like yeah yeah there are no
Jedi but they do exist you can go to any
damn Star Wars convention and see one
well and I think that you can
technically like have that as your
religion yes it was based on a samurai
that's where yes that's where the Jedi
came from well
the ninjas like that it's based on
professional soldiers of the fifteen
hundreds of what they were doing and
then they started to invent something
that didn't exist yeah now it exists
well yeah because in the 17 in the
1800's you started seeing dudes in black
suits yeah anyway yes by the time in the
mid 19th century rolled around in Japan
because we didn't really get ninjas in
the United States to probably the 60s it
kind of came into like you know popular
culture but in the you know in right
about the mid 19th century in Japan they
had already started talking about like
the shinobi had started to morph into
like this folklore and as the years went
on like more and more abilities got you
know attributed to them it's like oh
they can become invisible they can
swallow a whole bull yeah alive let it
go you know like they can walk on water
they could like make it storm or they
could like do other things like that so
it just seemed like it's one of those
things where it started out as like a
pretty mundane like I said it's just
mundane like covert action as you happen
in pretty much any war any battle ever
and they just kind of built this big
mythology around it that just got bigger
and bigger and bigger as the Year going
on where the look came from is because
the Japanese they loved theater in the
70 in the 1800s and if you ever see
Japanese theater there's always these
stage hands and black changing this
change in the sets or they're doing
special effects yeah and the Japanese
got really good kind of filtering these
yeah they're coca yeah yeah filtering
these stagehands out they didn't got to
where they couldn't see him well
sometimes they would depict a sneak
attack from from a sneak attack from a
ninja and it would be one of those guys
dressed in black with swords yeah
there's like a stagehand boom come out
of nowhere and start fighting this guy
and you just you could see the samurai
but you would only see a sword and a man
in black on a black background you
really weren't supposed to see the man
at all he was like a hidden figure
striking
from the darkness so that slowly morphed
into a ninja war black yeah I'm pretty
sure I mean from everything that I've
seen in like the research I've done that
does appear to be where the black suit
for the ninja came from it came from
theater yes from theater because I'm
telling you as a professional soldier
black is a [ __ ] shitty shitty camouflage
black doesn't occur in nature and you
stick out like a sore thumb and innate
daytime and nighttime yeah against the
president it's always green Green is
always the best camouflage and desert
it's always tan yeah you know if you if
you don't know where you're gonna be the
best camouflage is always just kind of a
solid field gray that works pretty good
yeah that can work a little bit in
everywhere but so know if there were
ninja they would not be wearing a black
suit they would stand out like crazy if
there was a ninja he'd be dressed like a
farmer yeah yeah I was actually reading
a couple of articles by these two guys
that have written a book about
historical ninjas and Gordon enjoy I
guess they don't really you would ignore
but yeah they're like the whole point of
these op Cofer operations were to be
undercover so obviously somebody's
wearing like a black silk pajamas is
gonna like stick out so they're like
normally they would dress like a farmer
because they did operations in rural
areas and they would even have like
weapons that looked like farm implements
and stuff there's like they didn't have
throwing stars and swords didn't have
nothing like that there were modern
ninjas today operating in a time of guns
that ninja would be dressed like a cop
okay probably oh you can move around
yeah no one really question you start
shooting someone in public and people
would be hesitant to call the police
because they see a policeman doing it
yeah so give anybody ideas yeah don't do
that yeah but yeah so yeah the whole
thing is that it's kind of a myth that
because we were just talking about it
before we started recording the show
that I was like you know all these ninja
movies and [ __ ] like that that came out
in the 80s
it's almost
it's this special discipline that you
can like go to school and learn and then
like they all wear the black and they
have like you know the swords and the
shuriken and stuff like that and that
really is not the case it's like they
were basically just undercover agents
who would be in these rural areas they
would go out ahead of a battle to get
information so they would just dress
like a normal person because they
obviously didn't want to draw attention
to themselves which you would if you
were walking around in that outfit now
here's here's something else you have to
consider throughout all these eras the
1500 1600 seventeen and eighteen
hundreds in in Japan they had traitors
and they had assassins they had spies
but these were samurai doing most of
this yeah but they probably blame [ __ ]
on the ninja check this check this one
out you got a boss all right whoo he's
uh he's got an enemy who's another boss
okay yeah that boss approaches you
because you're one of his security staff
and says you know I'll give you all this
kind of gold and an inn and a job over
here and my fief my fiefdom if you kill
your boss and get away with it
so what you do is on one of the nights
where you have in guard duty you stab
the damn boss with your sword or
somebody else's sword or a knife throw
it on the ground and then call for help
and you say yeah I saw a ninja come down
out of the sky out of the damn rafters
stabbed you run across there
the thing didn't leave any footprints
okay and jump down into the moat and ran
across the top of the water and vanished
yeah they might believe that based on
stories of the ninja they're going to
look it had to be a ninja there's no
footprints of course it had to be a
ninja look who else could run across the
top of that water yeah and once it had
been a cultural thing you could use the
ninja you could use that as like a scout
and you could use it as a cover sure
which might action which would call
the ninja stories to proliferate it
would keep it going that's it yeah
that's actually a good point because you
know yeah you could get away with all
kind of stuff and then just be like a
ninja no way there was some crazy I'm
coming crazy ass stories about the ninja
running silently and faster than a man
can run they could cover 150 miles a day
they could run across the top of water
they could climb up sheer walls those
stories had to come from lies yeah
or you know like I said we've done a few
episodes about kind of like urban
legends or folklore and stuff like that
and I think that's kind of exactly what
the modern conception of the ninja is
it's just this kind of you know they're
they're basically a fictional character
that was built on kind of like you know
a normal mundane part of battle or part
of war whatever and then as it went on
it just seemed like it became at like a
self like you know just like a
self-fulfilling prophecy because then if
people started thinking they were real
then people would attribute like you
said they would attribute [ __ ] to ninjas
and then people would believe that and
then the stories would get bigger and
bigger if you were a trusted bodyguard
they never really believed that you did
it they'd rather write that a ninja did
it and that a ninja doesn't leave
footprints and that a ninja can run
across the top of the water because
that's what they heard yeah so I said oh
it had to be a ninja couldn't Bend you
had to be a ninja there's no football
it's like it's no fun I wouldn't do such
a thing and you know and the lack of
evidence would be the proof yeah that's
exactly right that's what I'm kidnapped
lack of evidence would be the proof that
it was a ninja in the thinking of those
days yeah and that they had like
supernatural powers right which a lot of
them were supposed to have Ron
especially I don't II it came from these
stories of murders that they couldn't
damn explain yeah they didn't want to
blame the person who was even though
that's probably the murderer
so yeah accuse him so you had to make up
an excuse me I was some damn ninjas yeah
it was like there's it yeah so sneaky
yes my lord I know you didn't do it I
know you didn't kill your wife yeah that
kind of stuff the ninjas game I'm just
gonna start blaming everything you want
CNN yeah it's my [ __ ] like that probably
cause ninja myth to grow and sustain
yourself so I feel like probably I mean
cuz like we were saying the whole black
suit thing which probably came from the
theater
the first depiction of a ninja in that
black suit in artwork was by the artist
Hokusai and that was in the early 19th
century so ya know yeah really not that
old and like I said they weren't even
calling it ninja until the 19th century
like before that it was always shinobi
yeah and like you said it was a video
game called tradition is about that too
but so by the time veggies that as a
code word for some girls tits if she had
a big TV oh she got some stares
Shinobi's on their high schools did you
know what it meant we knew it okay
although if you say it like that it
sounds pretty obvious shinobi's on her
[Laughter]
butt yeah so so by the time that the
whole ninja myths kind of got
transferred over to the United States I
mean it was already like a pretty
full-blown mythology in Japan yeah I
rate I mean I really don't think I think
you know the thing that kicked off the
ninja craze even though it took you know
quite a while for it to kind of come
into full flower I guess but was You
Only Live Twice
yes bond well the novel was never moving
right out of Japan to Australia with
some TV shows and then yeah they had
they had an intership
swimming got on it wrote a book about it
and some people knew about it but really
regarded in the mainstream was you Only
Live Twice James Bond yeah
and karate karate you know that was
already here so it kind of dovetailed in
nicely with some of these martial arts
stuff that was already good if you look
at the cheesy portrayals of martial arts
to the
teas in the 60s pretty [ __ ] cheesy
yeah it's like it's like the fighting
that Kirk did in [ __ ] the original
Star Trek
[Laughter]
it's way it's kind of portrayed but it
was you know I captured the imagination
I guess and you only that twice came out
and Bob goes to like a ninja training
school and then fight the bad guys who
have an army of ninjas basically I'm
excited Iron Man and it went full it
went it went full steam after that you
know but then there was also kung fu
movies and karate movies yeah that was
half that's like opened all of the kind
of opened the floodgates really I mean
like all the kung fu movies and stuff
but I think what that was kind of the
first mainstream exposure but the ninja
angle is that the had a damn
practitioner of ninjutsu in Japan who
was who trained the team for that movie
what was his name again you think you
got it written down a little the purple
hair - purple hair guy whose sake huh -
Mia had sued me
although I've also seen it had Sumi
Misaki yeah Japanese his first year um
yeah hit sue me this guy he made a lot
of he was so he was popular even in
Japan yeah you know before the James
Bond movie came out and he claimed to be
from a long lineage of ninja ninja and
that he he wrote a bunch of books and
claimed to have a bunch of old
manuscripts about how much maybe he did
but I don't think there were as old as
he was saying that they were yeah he was
a martial artist but I think I'd have to
say he was a fake ninja he was a fake
ninja in the Japanese bought it yeah I'm
saying the Americans I think when I mean
when he first started out he actually
started out I mean he was born in the
30s he started out in judo and that's
what he was teaching and I think that he
actually taught American soldiers in
Japan he taught them judo yeah like in
his younger
okay um so and after after that he kind
of went on and he found like a like a
teacher to sort of expand out his stuff
but he is like he apparently learned a
bunch of ninjutsu styles and spent like
many years like learning how to do that
or invented these ninjutsu style could
be there's there was a lot there there's
a lot of questionable [ __ ] in in all
this stuff and a lot of the stories and
a lot of the things that he said and
wrote down ended up being repeated over
and over again even in even in the fake
ninjas in the United States in other
words they all started telling similar
birth stories and similar creation
stories to how they became a ninja
there's just things like death touches
and [ __ ] like kumite talking about he
seemed to be a source of a lot of this
yeah well she doe even though even
though he wasn't a bullshitter I mean he
did he was actually a martial artist he
did actually teach um you know he did he
did judo I you know he's a real martial
art he is a real martial artist he did
like teach me I'm pretty sure is a fake
ninja though yeah and Leah I think like
a lot of his [ __ ] was like you know
exaggerated a little bit it's like oh
the ancient you know all this ancient
art if I'm come from a long line of
ninjas and stuff like that that's
probably exaggeration but he's not like
a dude that just like made [ __ ] up out
of whole cloth from my understanding it
was stuff he dug up yeah to ninja we'll
see yeah I mean so that important and
he's not that important in the history
of American Ninja soo yeah we just we
bring him up because he's kind of a
source of a lot yeah he came up on a lot
of like when I was looking at like
martial arts frauds and all this kind of
stuff he kind of comes up is not
necessarily a fraud himself but as the
inspiration for a lot of frauds that can
use later on like the prototype yeah
even though he's used right that's a
good way to put it
he's the product
that these frogs used yeah exactly and
you know it's funny because of the the
channel we were watching the pink man
where he's talking about what a bunch of
[ __ ] black belt magazine they put
like a lot of these fraudsters like on
their yeah on their covers and stuff
like that which i think was kind of
funny but like I said back in the old
days you know no we're checking you
didn't really have much of a way of
checking it's like it's much harder to
get away with this kind of crap you
nowadays people still attempt it I don't
know why they do but I don't know why
you would try to like make up this whole
entire story I could see why people
would do it back in the day cuz you
could probably get away with it like
especially like making up like the
military records or making up like all
this [ __ ] you know it not envision an
internet and a place where people where
people could actually investigate and
find find out somebody's background yeah
easy to do now but not back in the day
so you could lie your ass off but we can
get to black belt magazine I think that
we probably ought to just talk about
count Dante everything yeah we are gonna
talk about count Dante but you know you
you want to talk about count down David
what do you have next on the timeline
that's probably the next thing I just
have like a little bit more about hat
see me and just like I said he was
basically like I said he did he was
actually a legit martial artist he did
he was a martial arts adviser on You
Only Live Twice and on some other like
Japanese shows that were like martial
arts shows and things like that so you
know like I said he's not so much a
bullshitter but a lot of the
bullshitters that came out yeah after
him you know were kind of inspired by
him I suppose and he did he wrote like a
[ __ ] ton of books as well yeah but uh so
let's talk about County yeah okay I'm
gonna talk to top my experiences with
County yeah when I was a kid you know in
the 70s we'd have all these comic books
and in the back of these comic books
there were these ads cow danta you can
show the picture and it'll look like a
damn vampire
if they fire with the evil beard with a
[ __ ] cape and this [ __ ] hands out
like this and he's got a [ __ ] afro
and Blacula yeah I was gonna say he
looks very much like Blacula even though
he's not a he's a white guys like that
he didn't have an afro but he made it
look like he had it yeah it was just
like a round yeah and it was one of the
coolest looking pictures of all times
and I I saw recent it isn't cool it's
cool I'll add I like it
and that was Campbell meta-chem Dante
was selling training he's the most the
most dangerous man alive
yeah and he's making all these promises
about you know how much of a badass he
could he could make he just for you
bought his books you know and he talked
about the dim Mach you know the [ __ ]
poison hand the death touch yeah I feel
somebody just touching them you know and
this this [ __ ] all just kind of plays in
with the comic book culture of the day
oh yeah okay alongside those ads you
would also see ads for [ __ ] like Charles
Atlas dynamic tension cartoons about by
this pamphlet you can get [ __ ] huge
like Charles Atlas I remember those
comic but I remember those ass I didn't
tell but I don't know when they stopped
running they were they were within my
lifetime but I thought they made him
stop doing I don't know what year they
made him stop doing that so some of
these comic books I was seeing might
have been from the 60s from the late
sixties yeah but I remember that comic
book about the big guys kicking sand the
little dudes face oh that's a very very
famous yeah that's that's a 98-pound
weakling yeah I believe that was a that
was a hapless I think it was Syria or
and the reason why I mention that is
because as we kind of delve into this
fate ninjitsu fake martial arts you're
gonna hear over and over again
Tim mock the death touch kumite okay
you're gonna hear dynamic tension is
every one of these fake ninja second
claims to do dinette Charles Abbas
dynamic tension
yeah all right which is funny because
I'd be uninspired by what was in the
back of the comic books that's where a
lot yeah ninjutsu is common problems
coming from [ __ ] comic books
daredevil comic books and stuff I do
feel like there's a lot of that going on
and like I said much like the way the
ninja you know started out as like
normal [ __ ] and then it just got like
all this folkloric [ __ ] like added on to
it I kind of feel like this started out
a similar kind of way it started out
kind of like as a fictional story and
then like people started thinking it was
real yeah and don't for one second okay
Charles Atlas really was a bodybuilder
he was an early 1950s bodybuilder okay
he didn't get big he wasn't that very
impressive by today's stairs but he
didn't get that big to him dynamic
tension
same thing with Eugene Sandow you didn't
santo he was pretty big back in the
1800s and he sold people little
five-pound weights at his show and told
him just do that like 200 times and then
like the next 200 want like a shake
didn't get big like that either this is
what you sold to the rubes and really
all these little training Pampas from
from you know a count Dante were the
same thing they were like these they
were kind of like the shake weight or
the five pathway or the dynamic tension
they were a fake product that you sold
to kids or to really weak people okay
and it kind of acted as a way of getting
your name out there you could make a lot
of money off of rubes and you know okay
it's kind of like okay good way to put
it
[ __ ] sells a lot better than hard
training well I'm the average person
doesn't want to deal with any kind of
pain or adversity you know I mean so you
could sell them like a quick fix and you
can sell a lot of that and then they'll
quickly forget about it just like if
you're [ __ ] fat alright it's hard to
lose all that weight so why don't you
just you know drink diet coke and eat
whatever you want that'll fix that it's
this is that'll fix it
alright same thing if you're a little
skinny dude it's getting beat up
all right you really should go to Jim
[ __ ] put on about 30 40 pounds of
weight but that takes time okay and then
a lot of hard work but what if I just
told you I can I can teach you where you
can just touch a big dude and bring him
to it and he'll die and diarrhea is
death bring him to his knees you've got
a lot of suckers that'll go for that
fake training okay well it's an
appealing like like I said it's in a
feeling thing because like you feel like
it'll give you power and you don't do
like rug work for it right well dynamic
tensions like that okay the dim Mach
depth touch and all the [ __ ] think
martial arts is like that I kind of feel
like every single diet pill and every
size thing they sell like even now is
like that because it's like look they
always have like in these like
infomercials and stuff it's like they'll
have a super fit like a fitness model in
there saying that they got that body
just by doing like this little thing yes
five minutes and that is such that half
that did not happen
yeah like dynamic that's not what did
the what made that dynamic it's like
you're trying to pull one arm down and
using the other one pull it up one
muscle working on the other and they'll
convince you you can get huge that way
you want
you can't no obviously no and then like
and if some of it will work you know oh
you guess you could say push-ups is
dynamic tension I guess I did thousands
of those things in the army millions of
them you don't really get you get a
little bit dirt and a little bit of
endurance but you'll never get the size
Arnold Schwarzenegger you never get big
not just push-ups down dips in the
upside down dam handstand push-ups no no
you don't start getting a bunch of
muscles he start to sling it at least
250 pounds of weight then that starts
coming on but you know yeah so it's just
a quick fix it's a [ __ ] fix so let's
go back then down count daunting who
this guy is cuz this guy was really
interesting and in a way you could call
him a fraud and a fake but in another
way he was actually I think a key player
in martial arts and he was in a way very
ahead of his time and unlike some of
these other guys he could actually fight
yeah he actually did he
actually did trained as a merciless he
wasn't like just some yeah he was a real
martial artist yeah
very flamboyant a lot of charisma yeah
and that's every day and you know also
some kind of exciting he was a wild man
crime yes later on gets out of the army
decides he wants to be an army of one
and make his own go going to [ __ ]
karate and eventually he doesn't like
that so he makes his own dojo and then
he gets in charge of karate and then
he's running martial arts events and was
and here's the weird thing was also a
hairdresser yeah yeah he's a hairdresser
and it is his beard is like super
elaborate and crazy it's like it's just
this pointy he's a hairdresser he also
is like a part owner in around a porn
shop and there was something else that
he was involved in he lived in Chicago
and once he got his own dojo he called
it the black dragon fighting society and
he left the green dragon fighting
society that was the one of the ones
that he was here before no evidently was
a bunch of cops excuse me in the Green
Dragon Society but he started doing his
own thing and fights broke out and there
was something called the dojo wars and
he was a survivor of the dojo wars a
dude actually got got killed in it
I stabbed it for the sword run through
yeah but drop the charges though cuz it
was kind of self-defense they ran in
these a he tried to set blasting caps
around Green Dragons dojos to blow the
glass out evidently he they thought he
robbed a robbers safe and a bunch of
money disappeared at him I'd slow over a
million dollars he was a wild dude that
got it man
he's a wild dude then this is back in
the 60s yeah and he was doing all these
interviews about you know karate for
[ __ ] you know that it's not
full-contact well here's a funny thing
is that in his ads said that he was
chosen but because he was in a
championship and he built all that he
defeated all these different styles as
he was a champion of all martial arts
and really what they're describing is
the kumite and this thing keeps coming
up over and over
and even make a movie about it called
bloodsport yeah which was based on the
right Dukes which were great Dukes is
alive we're gonna talk about it later so
in a way a lot of this bloodsport a lot
of this fighting to the death no holds
barred nowadays you call it mixed
martial arts actually came from count
Dante yeah he does seem like kind of a
pivotal figure yeah you gotta put it out
there in the [ __ ] seat decide Geist
that there should be a no-holds-barred
full-contact sparring with no pads and
people could possibly get killed and
even when I was a kid the concept of
that was like criminal yeah you can't do
that man yeah that's against the law
yeah and a little did I know a few years
later that came out with UFC which was
exactly that yeah well you know so in a
way this guy's kind of foreshadow in MMA
and in the same way that Bruce Lee was
kind of won an MMA type situation in
fact seemingly or according to witnesses
Bruce Lee went and saw some of the
events that count Dante threw and
actually saw count Dante do stuff now
some people were saying that he wasn't
all that good but but but that he was
very aggressive some people that trained
with him and said no he was very good
yeah but he he even tried to get a job
in Hollywood but they said he wouldn't
he wouldn't pull his punches he would
actually hit people for real so they
look realistic yeah so he a lunatic me
got rid of the cameras guys let's count
down Tay tell us about I mean he's
actually I mean that's not his real name
obviously he's changed it to that like
yeah yeah his real name is John Timothy
Keon yeah and yeah like you said he was
from Chicago now he actually he was in
the military he was in the marine
reserves and that he was in the army so
he learned like jujitsu and hand-to-hand
combat and [ __ ] like that and he did
train under like a bunch of different
martial arts masks
during the 1950's and after he left he
ended up being for a while he was like
the Midwest director of the u.s. karate
association yeah and then he went off
and formed the world karate Federation
and he was actually one of the first I
think he was he was a co promoter on the
first full-contact martial arts
tournament which was at the University
of Chicago in the in 1963 so he ended up
like like you said he was really ahead
of his time yeah now what he didn't like
though was that and the reason he wanted
to get more into like you said what what
they would call today like MMA fighting
and stuff is that he thought that
martial arts was too much about the art
of it or the protocol of it dial or the
stylization of it where he wanted to
just he's like I don't want to have like
all these like different traditions of
it he's like I just want to use what's
effective right like for street fighting
we don't street effective so he wanted
to come up with something you know that
was just that you could use in a fight
instead of just like in a tournament
yeah it is a free internet age this was
this was quite hard nowadays you could
just you know go to MMA or you can
compare notes over over YouTube and see
what these other styles can do and you
know the guy before the internet you
actually had to meet and you had to
fight these different styles against one
another and that had never really been
done so this is like wait this is like
ahead of its time the idea is is that
let's get all these styles together
fighting each other and find out which
ones work yeah and then that's basically
we won't take the ones that will work
and we'll get rid of the [ __ ] inside and
that doesn't work and adopt new stuff
will make the ultimate martial art
that's kind of what he was shooting for
yeah and you could say Bruce Lee wanted
the same thing yeah yeah yeah so what
count Dante ended up coming up with was
what he called the Dante system or the
dance of death or kata Dante so you know
it was just all these you know things
that you went through now he actually
ended up changing his name but
Dante actually count one Raphael Dante
yeah in 1967 because he had this whole
story about how his parents who were
actually Irish American I believe and
we're actually fairly wealthy like our
upper-middle class but he had this whole
story about how they fled Spain during
the Spanish Civil War and they were like
of noble heritage and all this other
stuff I think he actually got the name
from Count of Monte Cristo yeah but yeah
so that was his whole story I
constructed think and like you said he
had like all these stories - about how
he'd been in Thailand in China and he
had like fought his way through like
yeah which dudes and that's the story of
bloodsport yeah that's like the coolest
thing yeah now around that time was when
he started burning his comic book ads
billing himself as the deadliest man
alive
and you kind of you would send away for
his little booklet yeah they where I
don't know how much it cost probably
like five cents or something touch it
how to [ __ ] people up and at the very
end he's got a picture of himself like
cutting a woman's hair and she got this
beautiful woman with it with her hair
all done any good it says just think you
know these hands could destroy you or
they can create you know he's trying to
get yin yang didn't create a master of
creation and a master of destruction you
know I mean he's trying hit me I like it
I complete man you had to be a creator
and a destroyer
yeah but yeah so you would so apparently
so you would get this little booklet
that was telling you how to do like
Dimock which is the death touch yeah and
you also get like a little membership
card to his black dragon fighting
Society
I love the [ __ ] and even his Wikipedia
page had like some a little pull out
quote from from one of the ads and I
love you know you can't really see it
because it's just in my notes but those
like the capitalization like you just
imagine where the capitalization is but
it says [ __ ] like this is the dead
and most terrifying fighting art no
demand and without equal its maiming
mutilating disfiguring paralyzing and
crippling techniques are known by only a
few people in the world an expert at dim
Mach could easily kill many judo karate
kung-fu Aikido and gung fu experts at
one time with only fingertip pressure
using his murderous poison hand weapons
yeah
instructing you step-by-step through
each move in this manual is none other
than count Dante the deadliest man who
ever lived fifteen year old boy would
not buy them that's pretty irresistible
I haven't just poison hand weapon you
sign me up yes you mentioned before the
dojo Wars yeah hold on let me say some
stuff about alright I dug up some more
stuff about it okay okay there was there
been say okay one of the things about
count Dante is that count Dante would
take students of any race yes that
wasn't being done in these dojo
yes it was still segregated there now
some of his contemporaries like in the
Green Dragons were saying that well he
wasn't doing that because he cared about
this he just wanted the money he was you
know abusing those people no they're
actually I saw some videos of guys that
the black guys that were at his school
they said they [ __ ] loved it yeah the
real deal the story was is that because
he was ex-service you know he was
already came up from from Anna training
environment where it was all racism guys
cuz the services were integrated already
yeah so the whole idea of taking a black
or Hispanic student just wasn't an issue
for him so he was you know ahead of his
time for the 60s and then another story
that I have is that one of the black
student tried to show up and he was
wearing his judo key when he showed up
and when he walked in the door all the
guys in there jumped up to their feet
count Dante was there and they all went
into a defensive position and tried to
start going towards them like to attack
him and then
he he backed out scooted out and he
realized that he he didn't he didn't
mean it but because he was from another
dojo and he just showed up unannounced
like that they thought they were under
attack
Jojo Wars yeah because of the dojo worse
ok at the time he just walked in here
cuz he cuz he just walked in and show up
in uniform yeah yeah he said he was so
embarrassed that he didn't go back oh
the guy he wanted he wanted go there
that I said he's so embarrassed he
didn't go back cuz he [ __ ] up like I
said they were taking this [ __ ] yeah so
the dojo Wars this actually happened in
1965 and count Dante actually ended up
getting charged with attempted arson
yeah now it was him and his buddy whose
name was Douglas Dwyer who was the
second deadliest man alive um they
actually got arrested while like you
said they were taping dynamite cabs
blasting caps to the rival dojo to
arrival dojo in Chicago yeah now I don't
nothing blew up they caught them while
they were taping him there now they both
said that they were drunk and they were
not really aware of what they were doing
here's over money or something like that
but yet money insults they were a war
yeah basically later on like count ante
said it was because I guess that dojo
and like owed him some money for like
some competition or something he hadn't
paid him and there was like this big
rivalry going on and apparently this
kind of like escalated
over the next five years because five
years later count Dante and some of his
little acolytes went over to the green
dragon societies their black Cobra Hall
dojo yeah they came in said they were
cops and then started beating on the
other cities now as we laughs but
actually the the fight ended up like a
guy ended up dying yeah like a learned
of count Dante is great yeah green
dragon grabbed a sword jumped up stabbed
ran him through his he was tired he's
gonna run run he told him to all go need
yeah they all yeah yeah Ron he's brave
to the end I guess it's like it seems
like um even though it did go like go to
trial and stuff like that yeah it kind
of got dismissed like the judge just the
wikipedia page says the judges give
everyone a stern talking-to
yeah I was it was so much you guys it
was self-defense
here we had they were the aggressors
true they went in there beating people
up and somebody defended himself and
killed the guy and they just called it
even the judge said that they were all
at fault that they were all all lunatics
yeah yeah yeah now it is also speculated
it's never been proved but there was a
this guy named Robert Cooley who was a
mob lawyer back at the time and he wrote
a book later and he said that he thought
that maybe count Dante was the guy
behind the there was like a big robbery
and took like a vault robbery in Chicago
in 1974 which over in which over four
million dollars was stolen and so he
thinks that maybe count Dante was like
so did not the only guy but that he was
like the mastermind behind yeah that
that thing that he was a question on
that but he passed a polygraph so they
let him go pretty much everybody says
that he had he had friends and organized
crime they were like black organized
crime yeah yeah he was friends with him
well that may be why I hate it and got
away with all this know maybe whether or
not he was doing crime where them I'm
gonna say probably probably but yeah but
yeah so he actually um he ended up dying
like before the trial was even over and
like yeah here's the best thing he died
a young man think about 37 he died in
1975 27 37 and I think what year was he
born let's let's look and he was born in
1939 died of stomach ulcers an ulcer
broke loose in his stomach lost all his
blood internal bleeding yeah no reason
why all that happened though is cuz I
think he's pushing himself pretty hard
he was had a lot of injuries from what
yeah because
said that you know he trained hard so it
was taking pain medication to deal with
the damage that he was doing to himself
and he started drinking on top of the
pain medication you know pain medication
and booze you know they've magnified one
another so I think he got addicted to
that no I screwed up his probably
screwed up his stomach lining or
something and that's contributed to his
death yeah he had bleeding ulcers yeah
but he was a wild he was a wild guy but
I like to hang out with him I thank you
know he does seem like he'd be a blast
yeah if you could keep him from like
punching it with the fish yeah this big
brown Cadillac and he put his Dante coat
of arms on the doors and he went some
some 7-eleven or something stepped out
and some guys started making fun of him
they called it a [ __ ] he beat their asses
they're like it's now mr. dead damn
because of the death he hit his cooter
arms on the door see he was definitely
like a dandy type of guy
oh yeah we're at a fantastic outfits
everybody that trained with him said
that he trained hard and that he was had
a larger-than-life personality a
tremendous charisma yeah and it's just
that you know what he was doing you know
they had with inner-city black guys from
Chicago that had no purpose we're
finding a purpose there and they had
also ex-military guys you know so it was
kind of like a Fraternal Order and a
warrior cult at the same time and
evidently he was very cultish very much
like a co this ice I feel like this kind
of thing it's like easily spills over
and yeah it was like it was like a dojo
from a kung fu movie yeah yeah you know
where they were training in there and it
was a gym and they had all these damn
weapons and I think they even said guns
were in there - I don't know if they
were shooting them but guns in there and
then they were going out fighting other
dojos and trying to figure out how to
make money and then you know the head of
it's kind of like a criminal cult yeah
yeah I guess it is that's kind of a
mafia kind of like a little mafia yeah
um
let's talk a little bit about count
Dante's claims about Dimock yeah because
this is he wasn't he's not the only
person to you know say that this is
possible obviously this kind of goes
back in
you know Asian Chinese and Japanese kind
of folklore for a long time that there
are particular places that you can touch
or strike on a human body that will
either kill a person immediately or will
have a delayed killing like it'll kill
you ten days later like some people some
people are saying that's what happened
yeah that like that somebody in mock guy
[ __ ] that like a few days later he
died which it actually if it did work
that'd be like the perfect plausible
deniability wouldn't it if that worked
it would work all the time and people
would be dying from it just in car
accidents and that's it you fall down
and press touch yourself the wrong way
yeah document
dim box I mean it is that's the thing
it's like it's kind of muddies the
waters because um you know in case you
in case you were curious where where dem
mont comes from is actually I think in
Chinese it means press artery or
something like yes yeah it's almost
getting into George Dillman what the
[ __ ] pressure point yeah we'll get it
we'll get into that too because he was
another guy that claimed he could do
this like in a different sort of way
yeah but it's yeah it's kind of like
this thing where you know it has to do
with like acupuncture and pressure
points and all that kind of stuff which
is you know kind of [ __ ] but also
but there is there's like a tiny tiny
tiny little molecule of like truth in
there somewhere because there is if you
hit somebody like above their heart in a
very particular way at a very particular
time in their heart beat cycle then that
can kill them you know what I mean but
you have to get it just right and it has
to be like the circumstances have to be
like exactly perfect or exactly you know
horrific ly wrong depending on how you
want to look at it it will give you a
cardiac arrest but it's not really the
same as like sneaking up and like doing
a vault
death pinched on somebody and having
them like immediately keel over or keel
over later on when you're like you know
oh you'll be dead in a little while you
know what I mean so I don't know so I
bet you they got the Vulcan death
pension [ __ ] nerve and they probably
got that from Denmark I think they did
because if you got it from there know if
because Dimock like I said the that
concept has been around I think since
the 12th century or 13th century some of
their been I don't know if it was called
that but it was like a similar kind of
thing you know
so it's goes back like a long way like I
said it's tied in with a Chinese
acupuncture so but um so I feel like
that's probably where they got the idea
and obviously it became like a big
cultural thing it's been in like a bunch
of movies not even like martial arts
movies that's you know it's been in a
lot of martial arts movies too but
there's been a lot of other movies that
have reference to that you know what I
mean like or all the different like way
but I feel like it's kind of as I said
it's kind of tied in with acupuncture
and it's also kind of tied in with like
people's Chi yeah which again is getting
into like kind of charlatans and kind of
territory but it's like I love kind of
some of the [ __ ] that they've come up
with like in movies like where they talk
about like the [ __ ] the five-point
exploding heart technique and yeah all
this other kind of [ __ ] one of my
favorite things on the Wikipedia page
like I said if you like I've Dimmick on
Wikipedia where they're talking about
Fist of the North Star the manga and I
love this last sentence where he says
the protagonist of the story will often
end a battle stating how much time the
opponent has left to live after
finishing the after delivering the
finishing move like he does the death
touch on him then he says how much time
he has left to live he says or he'll
follow up with his famous catchphrase
you were already dead before his
opponent dies usually from violently
exploding but yeah so there's all kind
of you know quivering palm death touch
that was from Thomas Pynchon novel I
think even like [ __ ] the remember
that old Quincy MA TV show about the
little examiner with [ __ ] whatever
that dude's name was I can't reward
factors name is right now but they even
did one about and that was like back in
the [ __ ] 70s I think it's 1977 they
did one called touch of death about
somebody that got killed with Tim Mach
and like I said we'll probably talk
about that a little bit more when we
talk about [ __ ] George Dillman
because that dude man that's that's like
his whole thing but alright so we're at
about an hour so we are going to take a
break right now when we come back we're
going to talk about more [ __ ] Oh
including talking about George Tillman
cheek and Frank Dux and the wonderful
machine again
delightful yes I'm totally putting
videos this guy there because I just
found this that's not funny so we will
talk about that when we get back
get that little mint baby Pookie get it
oh my goodness yeah right you're
fighting back it's getting away from you
Oh Katie get a cookie get it
just like man
like a tip on it Oh what I'm good too
huh
that one's good team mitten catnip
you're so spoiled you get all the fun
toys you love true crime
I love true crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume 3 is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
babies case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain vol 3 is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
all right we're back now yeah now it's
time talk about a cheetah camp let's
talk about a sheet again this is my
favorite yes she's like I'll probably
say one of the biggest first and the
biggest America straight-up American
sort of ninjas yeah
Dante it was ninja like but he wasn't a
ninja he didn't dress like a ninja yeah
I was really claimed to be a ninja
I mean this guy ashita Kim he's this
little bitty scrawny dude with glasses
it's a job to ever
he's so alive he's in his 70s now but I
mean he is self-published like by he
claims to be five six he probably weighs
about 135 pounds yeah he's very he yeah
he's a small dude um but so he's written
like a [ __ ] ton of self-published books
all of which are about ninja secrets
some of which are also erotic fiction
just about 200 as a prolific writer yeah
I mean you know they're not big you're
talking a hundred page pamphlets really
yeah and they kind of fall into the in
that same realm of little training
manual that you sell you know I mean to
kind of like kids and little adult
adventure novels that are a hundred
eight pages long they're bizarre and
then he also sells videos and you can
see them for free on YouTube I'm gonna
put the load yeah watch it man because
oh dear
well there's something kind of like
there's a comforting about well there's
something kind of comforting but there's
also something kind of sad about it
because I think maybe he might be crazy
because he seems like really really well
this double delusional well this get
into what he does person yeah I mean
here's the thing I gave him the evidence
yeah there's like not a great deal known
about this dude because it's like I've
seen his real name is usually I mean
obviously Ishita cam is not his real
name because that's like that's like
Japanese and Korean yeah yeah but um so
I've seen his real name given as either
Radford William Davis or I've also seen
it as Christopher hunter it's no one see
really sure most people think is Radford
yeah what his real name is I usually see
him as Radford Davis but he's kind of
like the best-known I mean if you do
martial arts runs google martial arts
broad and I t's pretty much the first
one that comes like one that comes up
because he's the most infamous yeah now
the weird thing about this guy is that
he's another one that he was running
little ads in black belt magazine and he
had his own website that you could buy
his products from yeah that buy from
Amazon or anything they gotta go
straight from him I checked he uses the
black dragon fighting society's logos
from count Dante yeah but turns out he
got sued for that yeah he had to take
his website down for a time cause of
that because he really he's claimed an
affiliation but he doesn't seem to have
an affiliation right okay but he did
that for years and not only him but
Frank dude ducks
Frank brain Frank Dux yeah trot ducks
ducks for the Dukes like but Dux to me
is ducks not yeah I know it I'm sure it
probably is ducks Beasley uh-oh it's
Dukes yeah sounds better than ducks also
claim to be in the black dragon fighting
society because they read the same comic
books I read
oh [ __ ] if we claim that sounds badass
if we could flee claim to be part of
that Association everyone will know word
for real even though you know most
people remember just from the [ __ ]
comic book so the comic book I had no
idea that a count Dante was a real
person
until recently I remember that ad yeah
well you wouldn't think that would you
because he the way he was like put
across in the ad he seemed like seem
like something's made a fictional
character that was a real guy a real guy
never dumb he was he was legendary in
the UK oh yeah I saw an interview with a
guy from England and they saw those same
ads and heard stories but there was no
way to really check and they were just
like oh of course it's in it's America
they got guys like that in America you
know cowboys and we did
[Laughter]
you look at that picture and you would
think that that count Dante and you
would think like nah that's [ __ ]
nobody's like that
but a court of people that knew him and
look at his history know he was all that
and more I believe he was all that and
more please yeah so let's get to a sheet
of Kinoshita Kim was claims to be a part
of that they were claimed at one time to
be part of that black dragon fighting
cease yeah but he's not he's a self-made
homegrown ninja he get he has he's
giving he claims to have a history that
somebody taught him how to do it I don't
remember how he did you might have you
do you remember his origin I don't even
remember what is it well he says that
he's pretty much can do everything like
every martial art he says that he's a
tenth degree black belt in one what what
one article said in a form of ninjutsu
no one has ever heard of okay yeah
he also but he actually okay as crazy as
this guy might be he did seem at least
to have the wherewithal to see the whole
ninja craze in the 1980s yeah and he was
kind of the first guy to really take
advantage of that in a big way like
turning out a lot of these books
claiming that he was himself a ninja
that he could teach you to be a ninja
and that all you had to do was like by
his you know his pamphlets in his videos
you know so is so in that sense he did
seem like kind of a savvy business but I
don't know much money he made over the
years on it he also kind of operated it
as far as I understand also operated
kind of like a black belt certificate no
yeah you could
he claimed that if you sent him videos
showing proof of your expertise in any
kind of fighting style he'd give you
condensers for it yeah and some you know
the there there is a martial arts site
that calls [ __ ] on these guys called
Bushido yeah alright and the the guys on
[ __ ] Oh said said I bet you he'd
give you credentials without seeing any
evidence at all well yeah if you paid
him I'm sure you waited and we said I've
seen like the certificate that it's like
you know yeah
tested of the guy said he wants his guy
said he was a fantastic black belt of
some kind of fake martial art their
martial art that doesn't have belts and
without any sight unseen without any
evidence he quickly sent him a diploma
belt in that Valley Kudo I think is what
the name of it that's right yeah yeah
and then they confronted and they say
hey man [ __ ] we were the ones that
sent you that and there was no proof and
you you validated it and that did they
don't even have belt anyway yeah in that
particular [ __ ] and blocked them
you know yeah he seems like one of those
guys that had bad temper he does yeah um
I've seen some interviews that's funny
because they call him interviews and
like I said you can see most of them on
YouTube
they're not really interviews because he
supposed myself
yeah he's by himself like in front of a
green screen background or like a blue
paper background and it's just like him
talking and then it'll cut to like a
text question right as though someone is
asking him that but you can tell clearly
he wrote the question wrote this out for
you you know what you wanted to answer
in that particular video which you know
I guess there's nothing wrong with that
it's a little deceptive but whatever and
it does seem like the tactic that he
takes in a lot of these videos is that
you know he will ask himself in these
videos about like all these haters and
all these people like picking on but
he'll try to be he'll try to like take
the high road yeah yeah and like get all
like sanctimonious about it bullies
about how they're you know did not
necessarily saying they're bullying him
but just saying that you know how
childish they are and you know they're
just jealous of me you know like that
kind of stuff so he's kind of going that
route yeah the dead giveaway for a fake
martial artist there's a lot of talk and
no fighting there's no video of a Sheena
cam fighting anyone yeah and there's no
record of him training anywhere of him
getting any particular belts or anything
like that so they'll give a class like
he was doing weird karai chops on a
student or something and it looks fake
his [ __ ] because he's of course not
putting any power into it
but we'll show you some clips amde yeah
because it's comedy gold so you know you
can't fight and as you said he's written
over 200 like tuner books with it
they're pretty short like you know [ __ ]
like ninja mind-control like secret
ninja alchemy and stuff and also and
this was the most delightful aspect of
the whole thing for me is that he's also
written some erotica yeah in which he is
the main character yeah and it's
supposedly true stories I guess I read a
review of it it's about Grand Master's
of the Black Dragon Society tell him
that one of the dojos is turned into a
brothel somewhere in Africa that's right
and he's got to go down there and
straighten it out but first he has to
prove himself another one then then he
ends up down there and it's nothing but
hookers with hearts of gold and of
course he's laying into him and he's not
paying for any of the booze and he saves
the day comes back and the whole idea is
that she the chemists very wise and very
wise and powerful and ultra ultra cool
dude you know and putting the wood on
these hookers you know yeah seriously
guys you go to a site called the Marcia
list yeah and do a search on a review of
the amorous adventures of ashita Kim
because that's what the name of this
Hyundai pages and the cover of the book
is him like mostly naked kind of I guess
he's got like shorts or pants on or
something like that and then there's
like a woman like sitting on a new lap
like a semi nude Lee and she's like the
face she's making is [ __ ] priceless
coach it's like she looks like I don't
know if I want any part of this and
she's like kind of backing away it's
like just the funniest [ __ ] ever and
like this review that this guy wrote for
the bar solicit for this book it's just
a Tom writing like we were land up at
the thing in the bed and like he was
reading it to me and it was just this
was the funniest [ __ ] I got a room
book now I'm not paying for it but I
don't like I want to read okay now in
the training videos one thing but he
shows he shows like ninja and visibility
and having hi oh my god so he knows this
he he throws a damn etool which is a
me entrenching tool and it hits the top
of a little hill and he digs a hole gets
in it and he says you could always bury
yourself if they walk over you don't do
anything and then he goes and then he
gets down in it and he's partially
obscured and he keeps jumping out ha and
he does a timer over it
ha and I'm like and then the holes
deeper do but the thing is he here's
what I pointed out while we were
watching this video I said okay so he's
digging this hole but the dirt is in
front of the hole so you can't see the
hole like in the video I'm like this
hole could be like this deep and he
could just be going to get back there
and like ducking down and then jumping
out you don't even like funny for me as
a soldier you know cousin came back to
my own legitimate ninja skills whenever
a [ __ ] infantrymen stops for he's
gonna be stopped for a long period of
time you you you you get a tool if you
gonna do by the book and you dig what's
called a hasty fighting position okay
really that's all he did was dig a hasty
fighting position and then he dug it a
little bit deeper wasn't quite a machine
gun pit and it wasn't you know it was
just a spot like almost like a slit
trench you take a dump in really yeah he
gets down in it and he's saying this is
a [ __ ] ninja skill that only it no
only he can teach you you know digging a
hole yeah soldiers dick you know
infantry soldiers on daily 85% of this
video is him just digging a hole and the
other 15% of it it's just jumping out of
it going yeah and then another one if he
let one where he's training you on how
to do like at a mock assassination
outside his house anytime he's supposed
to be so great there's no great going
along and then and then you hear he's
doing the voiceover
you know duck underneath the windowsills
so when he's up against the wall he gets
down goes in another window breaks into
his own house and then there's somebody
in his bed and he creeps up on it and
he's naked he says you know make
distraction noise not nature noises to
put him at ease
doesn't really make sense I'm saying if
the person if the person thinks you're
in the room make another noise that
sounds natural and that person will go
to heat that's now this [ __ ] works and
then connects to the bed and he goes in
you ninja can disappear site
and he takes the curtains and covers
himself up enough damn Kurtz with his
feet sticking out of there buzz hole
legs and if you were in bed you turn
around you'd see a [ __ ] hiding
behind the curtain legs but not in a
sheet of kimsworld and then he [ __ ]
comes out with a flashlight and shines
it in his face and there's a little bit
of voiceover like well that would wake
you up you know and I don't know if you
was was he supposed to be assassinating
the guy I don't really know it's just I
was hazy on the it was a spooky there
was a kind of spooky image really when
you think about this skinny little nerd
[ __ ] creeping into your house well he
doesn't even have like in these videos
like a particular that one that was like
my favorite one because he's just like
look I'm invisible and then like he's
just the top half is behind a curtain so
this is this big lumpy curtain with two
legs sticking out I'm like so that guy's
gonna wake up and roll over I go oh I
thought that was a guy oh it's just legs
asleep no he's hiding behind that
curtain it's like so but I'm thinking
because he wasn't he's not wearing like
what you would seems like in a movie
like a Halloween costume of like a ninja
costume he's essentially wearing a ski
mask I'm like he looks like the golden
snake killer like or mr. cruel yeah I'm
like so if you know if you rolled over
in bed and saw a dude and ski mask like
a looming over uhha black tight pants
tight like black sweater and a ski mask
yeah so it's like not even a real ninja
it's like a burglar outfit yeah that's
exactly what it earned like you know a
serial rapist outfit is what that is and
it's like the fun it's just so funny to
me because it seems like this is what he
is unaware yeah
that's why I think that this dude is
maybe has a little bit of mental illness
going on because he seems completely
clueless about how his videos come
across it's like you know what I mean
it's like this one particular one lucky
he's like giving you ninja tips like if
you're sneaking into someone's house oh
like go up against the wall like that so
they can't see you I'm like oh really IG
I never would have thought of that it's
like how the [ __ ] much and like you said
like ducking under the windows
it's like the stupidest thing ever yeah
and you know and then there's the whole
thing with like where he's there's a
couple - where he's like fighting with
another guy yeah there's a scene where
he's fighting with Sony named master no
no sensei Broussard Broussard yeah yeah
and Sensei Broussard is obviously
somebody who should put belongs within
crutches or yeah he looks disabled he's
disabled or he needs me in a wheelchair
he's propped up against the door was
against like the wall or against the
wall we're just kind of knock-kneed with
his feet and they don't have legs don't
move he has legs don't move so he just
hold himself up under pressure and they
got the lightsabers and they're going
through like a little light a light
sabers yeah it looked it looked like
well look like some dudes [ __ ] around
into LARPing convention for [ __ ] not
even as cool and not as cool as that man
and that's when seeing this [ __ ] and
here's another thing is that some of his
videos are him answering challenges and
he gets he tries to sound real fierce
what he's talking buddy he's a buck 35
yeah he's a little guy yeah and but
doesn't necessarily mean he isn't
dangerous I mean that most like it might
have might have guns yeah I mean just
shoot your ass you know but and I mean
it's like it's so it's just so funny to
me because of what will one the
production value on these videos I mean
they're from the 80s so you don't think
they're from some oh it might not be
from my 90s some of them might be newer
I think there's what they look like
they're from the 80s they look like
they're from like an old shitty VHS
camera and you know they're just shot in
front of like I said like a wrinkly
green screen background or like a blue
paper background and like the one where
he was like fighting the guy and he was
I don't think he was doing like dim mic
like death touch type of [ __ ] on him but
he was like knocking him out with like
one touch and the guy was like obviously
just faking faking it and then he's like
I know and I'll just bring him back to
life now whoo the videos are not
hardcore in terms of action at all the
basically his death move or hit the most
action you're gonna see in this is that
he runs up to somebody throws a pile
full of dirt sand in their face you sand
in your sock
you know bird tip that's about a swarm
and then a just I disappeared yeah
there's all this weird shadow on him dis
disarmed in centuries and I'm all about
that man and it doesn't work that way
you know I've been that century you just
don't do that you know I mean look it's
called a ride riding the Bears back I
think don't they call it where you get
behind somebody whenever they turn you
supposed to turn with it doesn't work
like that well and then spin you don't
and the funniest thing about that one
particular one where they were doing
that and they were doing it like in an
open field or like their back yard or
something
yeah and it's like clearly that's what
he was supposed to be doing that he
wasn't supposed to but like the guy like
turned and you could tell like in real
life that guy would actually see him
because right there right but you could
tell that he was like having to pretend
that he didn't see him like he told him
for the video it's like I'm not here
okay pretend you can't see me so he's
just like turning around looking right
out the guy and they're just gonna where
is he oh my god he's a ninja I can't see
him yes and it's just like oh it's
hilarious once you put all this together
and his writings and what he's teaching
I'm just gonna I'm just saying yeah but
said he's he's probably like one of the
first prototype LARPers it's kind of a
live action role-playing he strikes me
as a fantasy prong kind of angry yeah
[Music]
fantasy role player you know live-action
role play and yeah and some of the [ __ ]
that he's doing in his videos is just
basically shitty sleight of hand magic
tricks it's not even really good at
because there's like Vinci or something
yeah he's trying to like do some [ __ ]
like this and it's like he's looking
like a ping-pong ball and - and remember
he's like levitating yeah the levitation
oh yeah this one is so good you guys and
it's like I know some of you are
listening to the audio so you can't see
the videos but like if you get YouTube
like go look because go look at the
levitation video because he's sitting on
the floor cross-legged and you can tell
that he obviously just like puts his
feet like a nurse is like lifts his butt
up like an inch or not even an engine
and then like he has his little you know
his little assistant come over with like
a silver hula hoop yeah and like put it
under you know how they do the magic
trick and they put it under your butt
and stuff like that well they try to do
that
we'll just show ya do that we can't even
do that and it's like obviously he's
just going like one side and then he's
like turnarounds gonna go new I went all
the way under his butt except he clearly
didn't strikes me as a LARP like it's a
live-action role play and it's also he's
trying to sell books maybe it was
selling books to kids through black belt
magazine I get another fantasy
role-playing type people it's you know
it's only for the very only for the very
gullible with believe maybe a 12 year
old might believe that a little bit for
what not today but a 12 back in the day
check back in the 80s and 90s you might
be able to keep Simon a twelve-year-old
going for a while I mean that's about it
but he has been able I mean seriously it
seems like he's been able to ride this
[ __ ] train yeah they've been
challenged because he goes to other
countries like in lectures and stuff
yeah yeah you can actually hear him
talking on a podcast and he did a he's
on one podcast I think was from a year
back or so and he's saying basically
that he has new ways to be a ninja
healer he's gonna heal he's not gonna
fight and what it is is because so many
people have challenged outside and he
said well you can fight me but you have
to pay thirty two thousand dollars to
fight me oh it's the 30 mm yeah you know
a thousand I think but then there's like
some other [ __ ] that you had to pay some
other fees I think it ended up being 32
fighting and well if there's some of
those guys on Bushido evidently got
close to raising the money yeah because
you could stop so I said yeah exactly so
there Mon we don't yeah so so he's not
in the fighting business anymore besides
he's in his early 70s now yes that was
another thing and I was gonna mention
that before is he had when he called
back then the $10,000 challenge and you
think Oh $10,000 that means if I best
you in fighting that you'll give me
$10,000 no that's not what that means
get a pig that means you have to pay him
$10,000 for the honor of fighting yeah
but there were also a bunch of fees on
top of that I think it all had it up to
about 32,000 man that's like which is
probably maybe that's what he made in a
year books yeah maybe I don't know
that's just that's very funny to me and
it like I said it's it seems like if it
got to a point where people
seems like they might actually be like
racing the money and actually do it
that's probably the time that he was
like yeah I'm out
I do get flattened in a fight yeah I
fight that would be in those videos
that's what I figured and it's like you
can tell that I mean whether he's had
any martial arts training or not I can't
really say it doesn't really look like
maybe in a maybe in a very minor
capacity slits but it really doesn't
look like I mean from what I've seen of
the videos like the way he moves the way
he does like I just can't his students
or assistants or whatever whoever's
working with him in these videos look
like other LARPers yeah it does kind of
look like kind of overweight larper type
just like a bunch of dudes yeah listen
around financial that seems like what
they're doing it's just like yeah it's
like people it's like down to the
Dragons but for ninjas yeah I feel like
we should talk about Dillman yeah but
I'm just but seriously googled the
amorous adventures of Ishida Kim yeah
the Marsha list and you read that
[ __ ] room you just look at a sheet of
Kim's videos on you - oh my god
hilarious but like I said I'll put some
in he's got him up there he's got him up
there for all the world to see he won't
he's gonna put him up now comments are
disabled well I could have many other
people have mirrored dead I can't on
this probably like I said you probably
get a like wayback machine or something
like that and see what they were so
alright but yeah go go watch the cheetah
Candace likes it it's it's comedy gold
alright so now let's talk about George
Dillman yeah George George Dillman his
name is some usually comes up as
synonymous with pressure point mmm-hmm
whenever you hear it when when you're a
kid you tell me let me use this pressure
point just pressure that's Dillman yeah
the diamond was a real martial artist at
one time he even worked with Muhammad
Ali but Muhammad Ali was kind of using
him for PR I think and next thing you
know it old Dillman's [ __ ] black belt
magazines sucking his dick and [ __ ]
Dillman's out their throne damn
invisible chi balls knocking down
[ __ ] dozens of people that
yeah there's some pretty funny video
yeah when he was younger and thinner you
you could buy that he was a martial
artist in those days you look at him you
look at him now
well he's just like a tubby I'll tell
you old dude tale he's lying
all right you can tell he's I'm going to
tell stories well he seems like ok now
this guy - okay like with a cheetah Kim
I think like I said that guy might have
like legit he'll help us yeah but this
guy I get more of a fraud vibe like he
knows that he's bullshitting but because
it seems like whenever he's caught in
stuff he's always got like yeah use or
he's got some crazy story to like
explain those facts what I was telling
you before something it's easier to sell
quick fix [ __ ] to people who are out
of shape but have money yeah a person
who's out of shape doesn't really want
to put much into this as a sport or a
fighting sport is willing to go into
that kind of culty dojo environment pay
a certain amount of dollars a month and
then to have some instructor tell them
that yeah you can now knock over the 250
pound man just by [ __ ] touching him
on this spot right here
you're unbeatable yeah you're beatable
like I said it's it's a very seductive
thing to tell somebody especially you
don't have a lot of physical power but
yeah very dangerous you were gonna get
your [ __ ] ass green you're given very
vulnerable people and helpless people
you're giving them a very dangerous
false sense of security
yeah where you could have a situation
where some gullible woman thinks she can
take on this 200-pound man who step
aside I will solve this you know I mean
and she goes up there and try some
[ __ ] crazy pressure point and there
dude just shrugs it off and just knocks
her jaw yeah it takes her purse you know
you don't know that's it yeah that's
what I mean I mean a lot of a lot of
women have our kind of protected in a
certain way because
men are a normal man is not apt to knock
a woman's block off
they got psychos out there yeah on these
other shows we talk about these rapes
and murders the opening move is usually
the dude just [ __ ] knocks her out
yeah but with a blow to the head yes and
they're out there so given given
vulnerable people that a false sense is
cured you like that I think it's
criminal I mean that's the thing and
it's like there's a fine line there's a
fine line between like confidence yeah
like walking down the street like
looking like not a victim right and
thinking that you can kick anyone's ass
yeah who you come across with a passion
point yeah that's a very dangerous
that's a very dangerous misconception to
have yeah I think yeah chihuahuas have
that yeah that's what I mean it's like
you shouldn't you know you shouldn't go
around like looking like a victim or
anything like that
but don't go around thinking you can
whip everyone's ass either because
obviously there's always someone's gonna
be a little yes no Cynthia Rothrock you
might be able to stand up the average
dude it doesn't he's not a trained
fighter yeah you know back when she was
in her prime she was pretty good yeah
yeah so what yeah so I feel like okay so
that's another thing here let me put the
meat gotta give a copy out all these
martial arts listen these fake martial
arts or bad martial arts are outmoded
out of style martial arts a lot of these
martial arts become kind of
old-fashioned or out of style or
outmoded because they would only work on
an untrained fighter a real martial art
is something that a trained fighter is
using these techniques against another
trained fighter and it works yeah you're
getting an advantage a lot of these a
lot of these old martial arts they might
work on an average untrained person but
they're not gonna work on a real train
martial on a real trained fighter yeah
so I'm just trying to put that out there
that yeah you could beat somebody's ass
with an obsolete [ __ ] karate move but
that guy was untrained yeah okay and
honestly I oh I've always thought that
if you are going to learn any martial
art
I think it would be better to learn
something having to do with grappling
more than because that's where Morse
yeah because that's where most fights
are gonna end up you're both gonna be on
the ground rolling around so I think
that would be a better thing than like
although learning to punch and kick is
good too but MMA is a mixture of all
that yeah and then all of that happens
and like I said I think it's good that
at this point they've kind of like we're
finding the MMA and everything like that
like refined all the [ __ ] that actually
works in a fight rather than and I'm not
saying there's not like an art to you
know martial arts obviously but it's you
know I've heard some old fighting in
martial arts or two different things
yeah personal old-timers say that MMA is
fighting but it isn't martial arts I
kind of disagree I mean guns is fighting
guns as a martial art - yeah there are
guys that are fantastic shots and trick
shots and guys that are [ __ ] tactical
gurus that you know all kinds of [ __ ]
and hold teams of guys that are trained
together it is a martial art it is
something that you know it's a bunch of
tactics that have been refined tend to
kill them people with weapons yeah
because you know you don't you can't do
it with fists anymore you need other
weapons you know [ __ ] look at someone
John wick movies not real realistic but
what they're you know Kenny Reeves can
actually shoot like that I'm seeing it
like that at the range so what is a
martial art martial artist son any kind
of skill you learned that you can use in
combat yes an amazing martial art you
asked me yeah I'm like I said they do
use a lot of like traditional what
people would think of as martial arts
techniques right you know what I mean
even if they're not using them in its
necessarily traditional way right but
they're using them like you said the
more like more like count Dante wanted
we're right you know just [ __ ] that was
a fact right and that's where all that
[ __ ] came from anyway it's the process
of evolution
yeah the old stuff isn't necessarily the
way it doesn't have to stay frozen and
Evelynn time like that now like we were
saying about George Dillman now this is
another guy that comes up a lot more
talking about martial arts frauds even
though from everything I've read I mean
he does have actual martial arts
training he's not just like some Rando
like I said he's just coming out saying
he did this done the other thing
but he usually gets kind of like um you
know kind of put into that group because
of his claims about no touch knockouts
you know summoning chi balls that kind
of stuff
and the fact that he's been asked to
like prove that he can do this like you
know give scientific you know evidence
of it and he won't do that so I think
that's what makes him controversial more
than just saying like oh he can't do any
merciless because apparently like you
said he worked with mama Dali he did you
know he won awards he did that kind of
[ __ ] so he's not like completely pulling
everything out of his ass yeah he worked
for Muhammad Ali Mohammed Ali Ali wanted
to know how to defend himself against
karate or some kind of an oriental
Marduk martial artist yeah that's really
what you got
cuz it's money and I didn't really know
a lot about this but it does seem like
martial arts you know the you know the
the kind of heyday of it which you know
when they come food movies and [ __ ] with
in the 70s and whatnot but then like
once UFC and MMA and stuff like that
started coming along yeah I feel like
all the traditional martial to fade out
that's why we don't really have you
don't really see like a lot of news you
can take those guys and put them in UFC
here and get my ass kicked
yes I lost my street cred I guess so
like and like I said there's still I
feel like in the martial arts community
there's still kind of like that you know
that conflict with the MMA because like
you know some of them complain about all
these MMA guys and they were like Oh put
him in the ring with us and we'll kick
their asses the most famous martial
artists and that actually made the
transition in the UFC and MMA type
fighting would be the Gracie's with
their Brazilian jiu-jitsu yeah but that
was a rational system that they had and
they were actually actually fighting
they were fighters it looks a little bit
their little system looked like
something from MMA so it survived cuz it
made sense yeah they were working on
something that worked yeah I don't know
if it's up totally up to date nowadays
but still probably pretty good
yeah the Gracie's were
pretty legendary but um yes so like I
said Dillman is like one of the in its
problems this is probably I'm you I
think it's on YouTube because we saw it
on there but I feel like he's first
started talking about like this no touch
type of thing in the early 1980s in
black belt magazine kind of you know the
they kind of championed it he had come
up with this new method yeah what
they're talking about in case you don't
know they they were saying that you
could sit and sometimes you'd see it in
these old damn video games where you
could [ __ ] a fix back and then pull a
bunch of Chi energy into it and then you
know in the video game or an animated
like a bunch little balls going in going
in and then you could punch somebody and
send all that energy into him right we
just call that really punching the [ __ ]
out of somebody Marcy these these ninjas
are trying to explain it in terms of
cheap well some guys were taking it to
the next level to where they could just
get the Chi to like form up inside their
their hands and they could just throw
the ball out and that that invisible
ball of Chi could knock yet it was a no
touch no yeah that's what they're
talking about you'd see that in Street
Fighter with like can so much oh yes she
bought that it doesn't work well clear
doesn't work well and the thing about it
is that even you see like George domini
giving like quote-unquote demonstrations
of this and you can tell that either a
the people are knowing participants that
he is told hey I'm gonna like do this at
you and you fall over or it's kind of
like a thing with like you know how
faith healers do that [ __ ] where they
put their hand in yours like David
you're healed and then they go and then
they pass out just because because
they're so into it
it's a code that they want to play along
so I feel like one of those two things
is going on in this situation trying to
make they're trying to make George look
good and they're just you know maybe
they believe it to a certain extent so
my there might be some psycho
cymatics gone involved that's what I
yeah but I kind of feel like them said
that's why I make the fig a put a
skeptic out there nothing happens which
very famously and this is when Dillman
lost a lot of his credibility was in
2005 you know the National Geographic
Channel they had that show I don't know
if it's on anymore but it's called is it
real and they wanted to see a
demonstration of his knockout chi ball
and so they had like somebody that
didn't believe in any of it and so he's
standing there like in going yeah man
knocked me out with your [ __ ] Chi
ball and he does it and the guys just
stand there going yeah I got nothing and
he's just like standing there now the
best thing about this show is that at
the end of it when they're asking
Dillman was like hey why didn't it work
on the skeptic or anything like that
Dillman didn't say you know oh I'm full
of [ __ ] or oh it doesn't work or
anything like that he came up with he's
like okay one it doesn't work on
non-believers like so you have to
believe in it so again like a favor song
was on his eye maybe his tongue was on
the wrong side you can nullify it like
that I'm like I don't tell everybody
that yeah yeah you could nullify if you
have one toad one so down one two up and
if you keep switching it then you can
you can block so I'm like so you just
told everybody how to like keep from
getting killed by you cuz yeah and in a
flash this guy's career was just [ __ ]
vanished pretty much well yeah and I
don't even think black belt magazine
will put him in after that
magazines getting smaller and smaller
and smaller as it goes I mean you know
why would you why would you order why
would you read a black belt magazine
yeah they just they just it's not
popular it's just like I said and I've
said this before when you know when we
talked again about like you know cult
leaders or people that people that make
their living by lying and bullshitting
to me it just seems like it just seems
like so much work man yeah it's like all
this kind of [ __ ] that you have to come
up with and then you get caught in the
lie yeah and then they come up with even
stupider lies like to cover up the lie
that they got caught it
it's like the [ __ ] about the toast like
how didn't even come up with that Oh
didn't you just come up with that at the
last minute no just not on top of his
head yeah that's crazy maybe we should
go on Frank Dux this time do you want to
talk about Frank Dux okay you probably
know a lot about Frank Deuce and the
antim yeah and you watched bloodsport
yeah I have I haven't watched it I
haven't seen it in probably like Franny
Doug's it's like the combination of all
these martial art lies all coming
together into one man the comic books
and everything had this dude man count
Dante you got the Japanese guy with the
purple hair who got his work in there
you got a sheet a kid mixed in there he
also claimed you know he worked with a
sheet of cam and they took pictures
together yeah things both claim to be
part of it for a while and Frank Dux
Frank Frank Dux I'm gonna call him Dux
that's Frank Dux Frank Dux claims to be
like a CIA a special assassin and elite
soldier warrior even though he wasn't in
service for very long and the timelines
are all [ __ ] up he's also a ninja
master he fought in this thing that he
called the kumite where he defeated 63
opponents broke all these world records
they did a lot of [ __ ] man and even
Hollywood made a movie about it was
called bloodsport yeah based on his on
this story
uh-huh jean-claude Van Damme plays it
pretty much was close it's very close to
this list of the claims then the claims
are frankly we're not gonna say it's a
reason to rise that for free on YouTube
it's it's a simple movie it's [ __ ]
outrageous it's like watching the video
game Street Fighter yeah John Van Dam
was like no street fighters actually
it's more like Mortal Kombat yeah well I
was thinking I think more I think well I
think Street Fighter was based on it I
think Street yeah actually
maybe based on but I don't know give us
a timeline Jenni
okay so Frank Dux yeah claims that he
was trained by a ninjutsu expert named
Senzo Tanaka yeah
who astute listeners will know was the
same guy that was in you only live twice
yes when he was confronted with that he
said well well Ian Fleming often wrote
about [ __ ] about real people yeah
that's I did yes there you go there was
a guy named that but the guy that that
Frank Dux was talking about like the
details that him right here's the thing
Frank this this big kumite there Frank
Dux claims that he was Imrie if he had
63 guys if you actually look at the
details of that this is the same kumite
that count Dante was talking about back
of the 60s bass yeah I mean or that's
where the idea came from you know so so
this is a fantasy that he picked up from
reading comic books yeah his life story
yeah I feel like these are a lot of
fantasy Pern individuals that are
reading things when they're kids and
they like the story of it so much they
make up that they just make a whole
young history about it right since and
it's hard for me to understand because I
don't really have that type of like
personality but I guess that can be like
really attractive to a certain type of
person so you can just come up with this
thing well they got famous off this
shit's they did it did work it worked
um well you know there's a fine line
between getting famous off [ __ ] and then
just like ranting on a park bench that
Frank was a big dude he could he could
beat you it was he's very Lincoln's beat
an untrained dudes ass he's probably out
six foot three maybe he's big dude
yeah so so he was somebody that could go
into a dojo full of these second LARPing
nerds and he could tell him anything and
they'd probably believe it yeah
especially after a movie was made with
about him yeah because that legitimise
right anyway there and he was all over
black belt magazine just oh oh yeah he
was on
suckin his deal all the time so yeah I
mean he could price ate whatever he
wanted yeah and those little dorks have
believed it he was another one that I
mean because as you said he not only
claim to be this big like martial arts
master and whatnot but he also claimed
to be a covert CIA yeah he had a fake
military history Medal of Honor or
flying cross oh yeah and it's like
that's the thing like they think that he
really did serve in the military
probably the Marine Corps Reserve from
1975 to 1981 but he claimed that he was
like in all these covert missions and a
lot of things you read about like say he
was a Vietnam veteran even though he
didn't join the service until after the
Vietnam War was over he couldn't and he
I don't think he ever went overseas now
they had pictures of him in his
quote-unquote uniform but the medals
were all wrong like he said he got like
every medal ever like a Medal of Honor
Purple Heart he got all that [ __ ] medals
all in the wrong position but they were
all in the wrong position that means
he'd never served right so like once
when somebody called him on it like okay
the first thing he said when they're
like well your military record says you
never went overseas or you joined after
Vietnam so what the hell is this all
about the first thing he said was that
oh well you know the government is
trying to like discredit me so they're
saying this that the other I'm like yeah
that's super likely and the second thing
he said when that picture came out and
people called him on it was that that
was a Halloween costume okay yeah so
this is another guy that when he gets
called out on his [ __ ] and this is
one of my favorite things there's like a
lot of interviews and [ __ ] with him I
was watching this one I don't know what
show it was from but somebody was asking
him like true and false questions and
he's sitting there with his like
sunglasses on inside my [ __ ] Corey
heart like a douche yeah and like so
what happens is if he says something in
an interview and then somebody later
calls him out on the [ __ ] he'll say
that that wasn't really me that was one
of my doubles because I'm a CIA
operative and I'm like super important
and super secret and [ __ ] something when
he's got it engaged he's got to go out
on a mission yeah it's double will do
that
because the doubles [ __ ] and sometimes
they say stuff that's like unauthorized
so yes so that was his excuses not not
as crazy as the tow thing that the
Dillman came up with yes but still
pretty crazy yeah um you know that he's
like so like super secret yes bye and
everything yeah now I got him in here
he's like in the ninja magic category
because he does claim to be covert
operative with a bunch of ninja type
skills yes he's a badass [ __ ]
don't take no [ __ ] he was actually
recruited by CIA chief the head of the
CIA when they were in the bathroom
together yeah I need a badass
[ __ ] you don't take no [ __ ] okay
he's like oh I'm a badass [ __ ]
cuz my normal spies my normal agency I
mean they can't handle [ __ ] like I need
there's such mangina
yeah that's how he became that's how he
became [ __ ] an operative and there's
pictures of him in his spy outfit which
you know I've analyzed the photo he's
like in this oh that photo and he's in a
black leather jacket and on a table in
front of them is basically like some
binoculars and it looks like a PVS to I
don't know I couldn't you know some of
the en PBS
maybe twos and maybe like a one their
night vision okay another one looks
Soviet they are night-vision scopes or
night-vision optics but that's not
something a spy would use everything I
saw on the table was something that an
infantryman would use like the [ __ ] that
I was using when I was in the hundred
first and then you know and then in the
second in infantry with the five or six
you know something you put on a weapon
system like put it on top of m16 or you
strap it on to the side of a [ __ ] RPG
seven or something you know and I mean
[ __ ] because that's Soviet wouldn't
look like someone you might put with an
RPG but they're not spy it wasn't a spy
equipment that was just basic soldier
[ __ ] and that [ __ ] didn't even really
work that well if anybody's used that
old-fashioned I
vision is just like looking through a
green and black television set you know
the resolution was shitty I mean you
really couldn't identify to what what
you were seeing you know it was just
optics of that day sucks but he's got
him out on the table he's looking over
them real seriously yeah you still got
like this might this is my badass like
CIA operative phase yeah yes [ __ ] spy
equipment before I take on me to take
with me on my mission and I'm going like
you take that you take that [ __ ] with
you on a mission that was I say we
wanted to leave back in a berry yeah
that's like why do you want that crap
can't you get better [ __ ] than that for
the CIA come on yeah barracks we carry
that [ __ ] I mean it's like what like how
long exactly do you think you know like
get away with this crap particularly in
this day and age I can see like back in
the day I mean he did get away was it a
lot too you know he he was legit they
made a movie about the dude yeah like
I'm the guy that wrote the screenplay um
I'm pretty sure that the guy who wrote
the screenplay for bloodsport did not
entirely believe this dude story but he
just thought it would make a good movie
yeah and it is goofy the movie does have
a lot of goofiness to it that you look
at you it's a very fun movie yeah it's
definitely based on some Walter Mitty
yeah yeah yeah the middie [ __ ] life
and it fan and I think that might be how
the screenwriter approached it because
from what I've read I mean he didn't say
this outright but I got the implication
that he just thought it was a good story
he didn't think the dude was like
telling the church and at the end when
Van Dam's won it just shows all these
Frank Dux is greatest [ __ ]
times and how many knockouts at how many
victories yeah and you're watching you
guys what this is amazing this is a true
story this is some [ __ ] yeah because
soon you're watching it it just does not
come off as anything that could be ever
even remotely true it is it's crazy it's
like it's super over-the-top well yeah
because like I recommend it it is it is
it's super fun imitating but yeah like
his whole thing was that he would tell
people that he had the world record for
the most consecutive knockouts which is
56 in case you were fastest knockout
point one two seconds all this
other kind of stuff but and I think that
wasn't this on the pinkman's channel
where he said okay like for the kumite
to be real two consecutive components I
think 56 each one of them had narrows
the field by half paint man did did the
math on this math he's like for that to
be true to defeat 63 people in an
elimination in that type of a sign of
tens of billion it would have to be like
something like 70 trillion people get
the math right but he's like a pretty
easy thank you through yeah a
championship that has you know a
thousand people in it you'd really only
have to like fight four people six yeah
because like the way the rounds are
because if they're elimination rounds
it's like two guys fighting and then one
guy gets knocked out and then that guy
you know fights the next guy so it's
like however many rounds you have what I
think he figured it I can't let down
each time yeah it just doubles each time
so double that thing 63 times you end up
with billions yeah it's like more people
that are on the earth right yeah so he's
like so obviously he's like unless this
kumite was like structured in some weird
way that right or if it was done in like
some weird thing that like no sporting
thing has ever done because most martial
arts competitions are elimination comes
in change they have rounds and you know
this guy fights this guy this guy gets
knocked out then you have to fight this
guy that won against that guy and all
this other kind of [ __ ] so you being in
a single competition that's supposed to
be what was it over like two days three
days something like that yeah we had my
have backup Frank Dux his claim to fame
is that was this movie and his biggest
[ __ ] fear for his career is that he
fought in this thing called the kumite
he called it the coup bootay that just
means like a match yeah that's not a
decision that's a thing but it's just
it's a general he's telling us he's
saying this back in the 80s okay and he
said yeah it was a no-holds-barred
deathmatch it doesn't collect drinks
I'm the only one that's like talking
about all these different martial
artists coming together to fight each
other to see what martial art is the
best and you know I want you know and
they gave me a sword and like where's
the sword oh I had to trade the sword to
free children from Pirates yeah that's
exactly said that's right again yes
fantasy okay so really what you where he
got this idea was count Dante yeah okay
and I I don't did the schita can't ever
make any claims like that I don't think
so not that outrageous no not that I
know of and this is going back to count
on taste fantasy and of what he wanted
and also Bruce Lee was envisioning the
same kind of competitions this is pre
MMA it's this is pre UFC yeah so this
whole idea but no holds barred match
without pads would be something kinda
legal it had to be in another country
yeah
alright some dudes died yeah that's some
serious [ __ ] that's happening now I'm
[ __ ] hammock you have see it I think
they think they had one of them died mmm
a just couple yeah I think the bagging
it happens it's just that you know time
in which he's telling this story people
people have died boxing team yeah people
died boxing it's not a big deal but you
know [ __ ] there the time that he's
telling this story the whole concept of
this kumite is like some real [ __ ]
pirate [ __ ] you know the man it's like
real hardcore like criminal almost yeah
it's like Underground's like something
that [ __ ] like a Fight Club like the
Yakuza would be involved in this and the
ninja they'd be involved in that yeah of
course they would but you would be able
to see an OC in those
they'd throw sand in your eye the
curtain yeah Doug his claim to fame was
this big pretty my or death of the
kumite and the story that came about
around it and if you [ __ ] ever get
into this [ __ ] 80s Karate culture
you're gonna steer kumite come up over
and over in there talking about that
thing and the one that count Dante was
about and they're also gonna talk about
dim Mach yeah the death touch yeah you
know in the movie because Frank duck
said he said he had to demonstrate he
knew how to execute the dim Mach in
order to qualify it to enter into the
coop so he had to kill somebody so he
was reading a lot of count Dante and I
had to [ __ ] hit some bricks or some
[ __ ] like that I remember what it was
like oh yeah that's it you know okay you
can be in there you can be in our fight
to the death
yeah yeah where's our might to the death
it's just no-holds-barred some get died
and if they died oh well you know they
knew that you know and this is kind of
like the same kind of the same storyline
that was in a lot of Bruce Lee movies
yeah well like I said I feel like that's
where they're getting a lot of it that's
where they're getting a lot of the ideas
from comic books and movies yeah complex
movies and that's where a lot of these
kind of fantasy burn individuals yeah
get these ideas for what for what they
want people to think their life is
really like yeah you know what I mean is
they're getting it from some [ __ ]
movie and then they're just like
retooling a little bit and saying yeah I
did this then the other thing Frankie
Frank dusty get away from it get away
with it because he was pretty big and he
was trail he was a giant in a sea of
mental midgets I'm I'm so like baffled
by a sheet again though because he's
just like he's because he's a small dude
and like I said he didn't even have the
audacity didn't even have like the
decency to go to like a Halloween like a
costume store and get an actual like
ninja outfit
it's like he's just wearing like he said
it's a black sweatshirt black like yoga
pants or sweatpants socks and a ski man
but he also has he looks like a burglar
he also has some photo shoots of
themselves in real like black keys and
[ __ ] ninja clothes and swords and
[ __ ] he's doing like cool poses and [ __ ]
that when he was younger I mean it's
just depends on what they were doing
when you see them all together in a
meeting and there's photographs of them
they'll have them I guess in hotels
yeah absence centers you they're all
they're all sitting down you got a sheet
of kin you got Frank Dux you got all
these guys that they work with you look
at him you go you know that's a horror
con or a sci-fi there could
yeah that's a let's LARPers yeah that's
exactly what they look like they don't
look like martial artists they're all
out of shape too old overweight too
skinny just too little you know well
it's just mixtures of a bunch of you
look at them you go those aren't real
fighters those are LARPers because if
you put a bunch of MMA guys together and
take that same photograph you go yeah
those are fighters yeah those are
[ __ ] fine I mean I have to say
because I mean not because I'm not like
into like the martial arts culture as
much but I feel like once you are no
longer doing competition say you're no
longer doing torment you're like you're
fighting
um I really feel like if you know if
you're going to like conventions to like
give talks or whatever I feel like
wearing the [ __ ] I you know it's like
watch I'll do that
they're bullshitting that's what I mean
it this is laughing play like you know
it seems like dress up and you you don't
really have the right to wear that
anyone knew you're not when you look in
with them you might see you know
Rothrock she could fight but she wasn't
a pro fighter yeah and she isn't now
more like she's an ex martial artist and
she me and she was in movies and I was
like sure movies but you know I mean
that's fitting you know I mean but it's
kind of like you take a bunch of guys
who are paintballers okay and dress them
up as Delta Force and take a picture of
them alright you you have that picture
okay then you take a bunch of Delta
Force guys and take that same picture
and they're in their uniforms you just
look at the key you could instantly tell
you could show them to civilians which
one of these guys which is the real
Delta Force
you're gonna go yeah yeah you can tell
because these guys are hard they look
other than like Frank Dux who like you
said he's a bigger dude he's older now
obvious right kind of chubby but all
these I mean like Dillman or like a
cheetah camera so like that they don't
look like I mean Dillman used to be a
martial artist BAM you know days yeah
but now he just looks like a fat old man
and he's like still wearing the stuff
and his gay wearing his uniform and it
just I don't know him sensei and he
didn't have any flexibility it's time to
it's just he he went to pop because he
didn't take that [ __ ] seriously anyway
he was throwing chi balls his whole
customer base was about throwing G
bought chi balls and how to avoid work
it out I wish I could [ __ ] do that
man yeah don't worry about those weights
don't worry about working wear some
thought chief oh yeah sure gather it all
up in your hand gather it all up in
that's a cow you're dead and that's more
profitable well like you said it's
people you know people want easy out
yeah
because shits hard yeah losing weight is
hard I know it's like working out it's
hard dieting is hard it's like people
don't want to do it it's too much
trouble it takes too long it's like it's
painful so it's any way they can avoid
doing that if they could if somebody is
coming to them and say hey if you just
pay me 49.99 for this shake weight you
know what I mean it's gonna solve all
your problems so you can see why so many
people particularly run like New Year's
and stuff like that they're like oh I'm
gonna get in shape this year so I'm
gonna spend $49.99 and buy this like
thing I saw in an infomercial and that's
gonna solve all my problems I'm gonna
get skinny even though they don't ever
use it it's hard for some people
yeah it's not hard for me I like it yeah
you know but for most people in it yeah
I shitty knows me you know me I grew up
in mental and physical adversity and you
know the harder things are the more I
thrive in that ya know if I'm not
working out or doing this or doing that
it's usually stuff I want to do I don't
like to really do what somebody else
wants me to do well I don't know just
but that's the difference yeah that's
the difference between pro fighter and
someone who's l'arbre well and even
people that do enjoy working out or some
like that because I mean getting into
the kind of shape that some like MMA
fighters are in for example that takes
years and that takes like a lot of
discipline not just working out you also
have to you have to like to restructure
your whole life around that [ __ ] I'm
gonna have to do with your diet and
everything like that's funny
and a lot of people are not
to put that in it was funny from my
point of view is it's not long really
five years it's about what it takes and
you can get a good transformation in
about eighteen months but that's too
much for some people well when you're
young five years seems like a very long
time when you're when you're our age
yeah here seems like nothing yeah
because every it's weird because like
the older you get like the faster time
starts to give motion oh I know it's
like it's relative find out but it does
really seem like that yeah because [ __ ]
I you know how they have that Facebook
memory saying and it's like hey this
happened like six years I'm like holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] six years ago and it's like
you know what I mean it seemed like it
was just the other day so it'll happen
to you to kids um I don't think so it's
just like the regular [ __ ] like like I
said it's like his whole military thing
that he talked about
yeah he's thoroughly debunked probably
[ __ ] he's been thoroughly debunked
um you know there's all the kind of [ __ ]
about him I already mentioned him like
talking about the doubles and there yes
that was anybody who tells you he's an
ultra secret
[ __ ] CIA spy and he can't tell you
who he is you know the [ __ ] lying
well I mean he came out later and tried
to say he never said that because no
it's right on the cover of the book that
he said he was a secret the secret man I
think oh yeah yeah yeah and then it said
right there in the description a most
secret [ __ ] agent yeah and like you
know not anymore
I guess not know what the [ __ ] man just
stop it
just not it it just seems like too much
short like I said all this lying it's
just you talking to him you're not
talking to it might be a dog it might be
a double you don't know he tell you all
kind of crazy [ __ ] yeah one that kumite
they said well where's the sword oh I
had trade sword to free the kids from
the pirate from the pirate that's what
he said you guys he's not that's not
exaggeration pirates pirates down the
Philippines I think he said it was I
think it was yet a Filipino Pyrus care
for those kids he had give sword and he
had to get this word to them to trade
for the kids there's nobody said was he
had a dad it was something like that
yeah how do they come up with this [ __ ]
I'm yeah I write fiction and I didn't
come up with this [ __ ] well because he's
read a lot
I guess he's [ __ ] watched a lot of
movies
and I wouldn't have the balls to like
try to pass it office yes true we had to
come up with an explanation of how
where's my sword with he coulda just
said I lost it
well yeah we did lose it but he hadn't
do he'd long he doesn't lose it in the
mr. dick ulis in a [ __ ] honorable way
I lost seeing something he couldn't just
say oh I was moving in children from
white slavers yeah I think honestly I
know there's that whole thing about like
oh the big lies more believable I don't
think that's true
I think like the more detail and the
more [ __ ] you add to it the less
believable you were making it man me and
Steve you know we had this friend of
ours his name was Patrick we used to
call him magic because oh you've told me
about this guy you told me that let's go
matric was a [ __ ] pathological liar
yeah long story about the party barge
yeah yeah [ __ ] where he was watching
some people on a party barge and
somebody with all the ski-doo [ __ ]
ran through it and cut it in half and
[ __ ] they were all drunk and drowning
and he and his boy had a joke saved like
20 or 30 people party barge and this is
like [ __ ] crazy as wise and we'd had
to put up with these lies news yeah man
it that's exactly how it happened that's
how him he said like BTK there we go
yeah yeah yeah he was a lot like these
decays like a skinny me too that's
exactly how we wouldn't call me a liar
will you you just like that you know
yeah yeah not to your face thing he had
asked girlfriend his girlfriend was the
principal's daughter yeah yeah she was
super cute but then she couldn't put up
with anymore she couldn't put up with
him anymore and this yes yeah well it is
houseful from what I know I've only met
Steve one time you guys yes but um he's
G he stayed here once when he was going
somewhere else
but um means diva tour that [ __ ] play
seven that's what I mean it's like
between you and Steve I think you like
[ __ ] every ticket you're at your
school job right good-looking what's
just a good look wouldn't take you
wouldn't give that
there is no time there was this time
there was just no [ __ ] time we didn't
have enough time for the allowance we
were still working our way through yeah
we were in a drama club you know we were
singing he was in the band and [ __ ] you
know the minute he hit he was he was in
a band he had he played bass he could
play [ __ ] play just like Steve
Harrison [ __ ] Iron Maiden yeah six
six six
yeah but now he was you got see right
here this is some proof right here yeah
like cuz this guy your dear drama guy
you were like you were like in all the
musical yeah Steve though Steve is like
my twin brother yeah yeah I like see he
was pretty cool like I said I've only
met him once and I didn't know him back
and he's not smart you know he ended up
in the human genome project he's a
scientist you know he's a biochemist
yeah god damn it yeah you need to talk
to him he also got into big nose
computers and he could do he made a damn
flight simulator and the heads that did
the 9/11 attack on on the damn Twin
Towers mm-hmm they had his program oh
[ __ ] I didn't know that yeah they they
came and interviewed him about it you
know but then it was no big deal just
because it was commercially available
yeah it's like what do universally
available for a simulator it's just kind
of like you make anything and somebody
is is it to kill somebody else yeah
Steve now that's now that now that I
[ __ ] lift Steve's by an innocent he's
got that y'all are still it's ready
competition we don't even man
competition you don't even like I mean
you still you guys still talk to each
other our basic like yeah messenger
everyday pretty much really oh yeah I
know you guys yeah like I said I've only
met him one time but I've heard of I
heard about him a lot
for a minute yeah because he was like
best buddies and they were just talking
about the women they were plowing
through back then yeah miss high school
I get tired of each switch yeah you care
though they didn't care they were like
us thank you
yeah I can see are you done yeah okay I
think I'm probably done dude yeah but
you probably okay yeah all right so we
are gonna wrap up episode 158 about
ninjas and [ __ ] Oh as they call it
yeah
martial arts chicanery various types
hope you guys enjoyed it probably go
back to the true crime next week cuz I
feel like it's been like three weeks now
where we haven't actually done murders
and [ __ ] yeah I feel kind of weird about
it
got any more stories of Christ ninja Jim
and Jim will try to whip my ass one time
because we always raced him racing him
to Denny's he had a break in your car or
like unfuck okay I was actually in bills
car oh my stepdads car racing to Denny's
in [ __ ] Jim Big Jim was in his
brand-new car you must get moons over my
hammy he bought one of those [ __ ] Fox
Body Mustang 5.0 is brand new
yeah he started to [ __ ] beat me so I
know I can turn right as fast as I could
he had his [ __ ] slam on the brakes and I
cut in the lane in front of him he was
[ __ ] pissed cuz he thought I was
gonna [ __ ] Dennis brand-new Mustang
when I got the plug and got a [ __ ]
Denny's he tried to kick my ass as she
just can't stop it didn't work though
going like that yes yeah if you're doing
that if you're you know I'm doing the
issue to Kim well yeah I'm killing you
yes talked about of it so dude man we
got [ __ ] to do yes we've got pancake I
said that [ __ ] cars we're not right
for this said that cars are sure I just
got it this is sure about Jimmy right I
knew you had good reflexes man you watch
Mad Max five times you know that kind of
stuff
because he liked Mad Max two dudes yeah
they're adorable I was about 17 that
have been really funny it was older than
us he's older than us I think by two
years okay but he didn't seem like it
seemed like he's about to see what
seemed really immature again yeah he
seemed like he's about 15 I didn't have
a girlfriend he eventually got one
well what like why not what was the
matter with him really didn't weren't
interested that dude just kind of you
know nerdy nerdy
back in the 80s there's a lot of well
nerdy's yeah a lot wrong with it I feel
like now nerds have it easier now yeah a
lot easier but back in the 80s man you
were [ __ ] suck yeah cuz I feel like
now like everybody's kind of dojo ass be
like was dude standing in there and
there's karate ready stance wherever he
was going walk around barefoot like he's
getting ready to kick somebody and [ __ ]
no boy yeah okay Chuck Norris [ __ ]
mullet yes Oh No yeah Chuck Norris
mother did he have like a yes - did he
have a chest hair Matt no I he had a
Chuck Norris mullet with a shovel nose
[ __ ] beard where the Chuck Norris
mustache I got Shane because he was
young and just look like fuzz well yeah
yeah it was red he was a [ __ ] ginger
just like Chuck Norris and like me yeah
yeah he's [ __ ] I got some [ __ ]
stories about what well because my
ex-husband who was British was super
into Chuck Norris so I saw whether I
wanted to or not I saw every single
Chuck Norris movie even that stupid dog
one even the stupid one where he goes to
hell or whatever the [ __ ] I tried to
watch the Octagon I can only get about
15 minutes into it I didn't mind the
Octagon actually what's I mean it's kind
of a low bar obviously cuz there's Chuck
Norris movies were talking about but um
you know that was actually one of the
better ones
silent rage was actually my favorite
which you said you hadn't seen cuz we
were talking to her just this the other
day when we were at vimentin Murray we
were talking to her friend little swole
yeah who was also a huge Chuck Norris
fan yeah and he was very surprised that
I had seen silent rage in that you had
yeah I've seen silent rage many times
that's actually probably if I had to
pick the best Chuck Norris movie I think
it would probably be that one just
because it wasn't like a Chuck Norris
movie it was like a psychological horror
movie but that happened to have Chuck
Norris in it
unfortunately check it out there yeah I
liked it I thought it was I mean you
know I insist it's been a long time
since I've seen it but you know all
right so your mileage may vary all right
hope you guys have enjoyed episode under
15 like I said probably go back to the
true crime next week might do Edmund
Kemper I'm not sure but we'll probably
get back to doing murders and [ __ ]
because it's been like three weeks and
we've done other stuff so anyway
remember if you liked the show like
share subscribe tell all your friends
about us you know it helps every little
bit helps your the show that helps us
grow yeah I mean you know if you'd like
to financially split the show obviously
we have our patreon we have our blog in
which you can go to our Pay Pal account
if you would like to give a one-time
donation any little bit helps and we
certainly do appreciate it and we will
see you on our next episode
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]